commission a décidé de constituer sur la
création du fond Marianne et la
sélection des projets subventionnés le
contrôle de la exécution et les
résultats obtenus au regard des
objectifs du fond cette mission
d'information a obtenu du Sénat de
bénéficier des progressives des
commissions d'enquêtes
ce matin Monsieur Mohamed cifaoui en
tant que directeur des opérations de
l'Union des sociétés d'éducation
physique et de préparation militaire à
l'époque des faits nous avions souhaité
vous entendre il y a une quinzaine de
jours mais vous n'aviez pu pour des
raisons de santé venir devant notre
commission mardi dernier une
perquisition à votre domicile le matin
vous a empêché de répondre à notre
convocation nous sommes donc
particulièrement heureux de pouvoir
enfin vous entendre en préambule de
notre audition et compte tenu des
éléments que je viens de mentionner je
vous indique notre commission d'enquête
ne doit pas interférer mais vous le
savez avec la procédure judiciaire en
cours nous ne sommes pas là pour
qualifier des faits en référence à des
infractions éventuelles pénales ce qui
relèverait de la compétence exclusive de
l'autorité judiciaire notre commission
d'enquête a pour seul objet de se
pencher sur la préparation la mise en
œuvre et le contrôle du fond Marianne et
évaluer les résultats comme cela est
naturel s'agissant d'une politique
publique mise en oeuvre après un
événement particulièrement dramatique
que chacun d'entre nous garde en mémoire
à cet égard nous souhaitons savoir
comment vous avez été amené à présenter
un dossier en réponse au mariage le
préfet Gravel nous indiquait lors de son
audition que vous représentiez une
caution scientifique évidente je le cite
vous pourrez nous indiquer si ce
qualificatif vous semble adéquat et nous
expliquer plus précisément la manière
dont vous avez ensuite d'impliquer en
termes de mise en oeuvre ainsi que les
résultats que vous estimez à avoir
obtenu avant de vous céder la parole
pour un bref propos introductif je dois
si vous le souhaitez bien entendu je
dois vous rappeler qu'un faux témoignage
devant une commission d'enquête est
passible de sanctions pénales qui
peuvent aller selon les circonstances de
3 à 7 ans d'emprisonnement et de 45000
euros d'amende je vous invite donc à
prêter serment de dire toute la vérité
rien que la vérité levez la main droite
et dites je le jure
je vous laisse si vous le souhaitez
maintenant la parole pour un propos
introductif je remercie monsieur le
Président
je vais être assez bref donc quelques
minutes pour expurger surtout
un certain nombre de points
qui me tiennent à cœur
et que vous avez commencé d'une certaine
façon à rappeler
je ne suis dupe de rien mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs je suis duc de
rien
et sans préambule car votre temps est
précieux je vais entrer donc dans le vif
du sujet en toute transparence
je vais parler en toute transparence
pour vous donner les éléments afin que
vous puissiez vous approcher de la
vérité au plus près
mais je vais parler en toute
transparence pour dire aussi des choses
qui me déplaisent que j'ai entendu que
j'ai écouté et que je ne peux laisser
passer
je vais probablement j'espère pas je
vais probablement alimenter la polémique
à travers à travers ce que je vais vous
dire
j'aurais préféré franchement ne pas
m'exprimer ainsi mais malheureusement
comme souvent dans ce type d'affaires
l'un des sens l'emporte sur la raison
et sur la retenue
je le dis mesdames et messieurs devant
vous tous serment
et devant l'opinion publique
non non
et non le sujet qui intéresse votre
commission d'enquête n'est pas
l'expression de la République des
copains pour reprendre le propos
scandaleux car insultant et diffamatoire
utilisé par l'un de vos collègues
sur une chaîne de télévision en
l'occurrence Public Sénat
je parle de vous monsieur le sénateur
Daniel broyer il n'y a pas eu de
copinage dans cette affaire
et je vous prie Monsieur le Président de
rappeler à vos collègues la décence qui
existe cette affaire ne serait-ce pour
la mémoire de la victime que vous avez
cité
le premier copinage qui devrait
d'ailleurs être dénoncé c'est celui qui
dit votre courant politique celui des
écologistes alislamisme et ceux dans
plusieurs villes de France
voilà l'intitulé d'une vraie commission
d'enquête permettez-moi l'expression qui
aurait de la gueule si j'ose dire
je passe ce premier point parce qu'il
fallait l'expurger
ainsi je ne puis tolérer et je le dis
calmement
et je pense qu'aucun démocrate ne peut
le tolérer que l'on puisse lorsqu'on est
sénateur
élu parce que la chose a concerné aussi
l'autre chambre certains députés
et lorsqu'on est de surcroît membre
d'une commission d'enquête tenir dans la
presse des propos accusatoires avant
même la fin des travaux de cette même
commission d'enquête
je puis vous dire donc mon indignation
car ce type de procédé qui se substitue
à la justice Nord ni son auteur ni
l'exercice démocratique je ne fais aucun
amalgame parce que je sais que la
majorité des sénateurs et des
parlementaires ont eu une attitude de
dignité je ferme donc cette première
parenthèse
depuis plus de deux mois
j'assiste impuissant à ce piétinement
d'une sacro-sainte valeurs la
présomption d'innocence
alors que nous sommes aujourd'hui d'un
point de vue pénal au stade de
l'ouverture d'une information judiciaire
certains juges utiles dirigés déjà des
bûchers
je vous rappelle que seul la justice
accuse vous l'avez dit monsieur le
président
votre rôle ici vous le connaissez
parfaitement j'en suis conscient
et il ne consiste donc pas à accuser il
sera utile de le rappeler à chacune des
étapes
avant de répondre à vos questions
mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs avant de livrer ma vérité
en toute transparence
je souhaiterais quand même remettre les
gens les enjeux au centre du village si
j'ose dire son me dérober et sont
invités aucune question
je suis sous serment je l'ai rappelé et
vous le savez
il y a eu sans doute sans doute des
erreurs partagées dans cette affaire
et je vous ferai part au fur et à mesure
des griefs que j'ai moi-même contre les
uns et les autres les politiques
l'administration
mais contrairement à d'autres je ne suis
pas venu ici pour défendre une carrière
je ne suis pas venu ici
pour faire de la communication
je ne suis pas venu ici pour me
justifier comme se justifierait un
coupable parce que je ne suis coupable
de rien d'un point de vue pénal je le
répète
le fond est le plus grave à mes yeux
c'est ce que je vais vous dire
aujourd'hui
et j'ai des grilles contre elles
on s'attaque à une ministre
de la République
en vérité on s'attaque un gouvernement
au mépris de la vérité parfois
non je le dis
Marlène Schiappa n'est pas mon ami elle
l'a pas été hier et elle le sera encore
moins demain
mais non Marlène Schiappa
n'écoutable ni de détournement d'argent
ni d'un quelconque copinage je le
précise
je vous dirai
de quoi est-elle responsable à mes yeux
politiquement parlant
on s'attaque à l'honneur d'un préfet
Christian Gravel
les en vérité on est en train de
s'attaquer à l'honneur de toute une
administration
je ne suis pas en fonctionnaire je suis
citoyen engagé
je ne suis pas un hauteur mais je suis
scandalisé par la manière comment
laquelle
au-delà des erreurs qu'il est légitime
de rechercher on cherche et le terme a
été utilisé me semble-t-il ici même à
jeter le bébé avec l'eau du bain
Christian Gravel que je connais depuis
au moins une quinzaine d'années
est en républicain de conviction et un
homme de grande valeur
il n'écoutable d'aucun détournement de
fonds ena exprimé à aucun moment une
volonté quelconque j'aurais pu percevoir
de détournement de fond
on pourra discuter plus tard des choses
qui pourraient peut-être être un sujet
de discussion et de départ
on s'attaque enfin un homme
ma personne
on s'attaque à mon honneur et à ma
réputation
je l'avoue ce n'est pas nouveau surtout
depuis que le populisme
et que certaines presse s'est mise au
service de ce populisme et devenu à la
mode
mais au-delà de ma personne
l'on s'attaque surtout un courant de
pensée celui qui croit la République
celui qui croit la laïcité et celui qui
n'a pas peur d'exprimer clairement ses
positions contre l'islam politique
donc c'est un processus de délitimation
mais soyez conscient au-delà de tout
il s'agit de s'attaquer à une action une
impérieuse nécessité me semble-t-il qui
nous enjoint de lutter contre l'islam
politique
véritable fléau qui ne cesse de grands
grainer nos sociétés
et permettez-moi de vous le dire ainsi
quand je vois certaines lâchetés je
comprends tous les jours pourquoi cette
islamisme continue de gangrener cette
société
ce fléau vous le savez probablement
trouve aujourd'hui des relais quoi qu'on
puisse en dire et des complices y
compris au sein d'une partie de la
sphère politique au sein de la société
civile et parfois malheureusement au
sein des systèmes médiatiques
sclérosiers globalement médiocre qui
alimente le populisme et qui s'est mis
lui-même au niveau des réseaux sociaux
avec fermeté donc je tiens à démentir
catégoriquement toutes les accusations
graves et mensongères les approximations
et les contrevérités qui ont été
relayées
et qui a suscité la naissance de votre
commission mais aussi malheureusement à
travers un pathétique et j'y reviendrai
rapport de l'Inspection générale de
l'administration instruit exclusivement
à charge avec des approximations des
assimilations graves et là aussi des
mensonges
j'espère que mon intervention permettra
de mettre un bémol un peu de nuance à
cette folie quasi généralisée qui
entoure cette histoire ou des
accusations tranchées sont proférées
dans un esprit le plus souvent de
règlement de comptes et de vente de
détails pour finir en quelques mots
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs permettez-moi de
parler un peu à la première personne ni
voyez là aucune forme de prétention ou
d'arrogance mais la nécessité de vous
dire clairement qui je suis
quels sont mes valeurs et quelles sont
mes principes
je suis infarrouge opposant et peut-être
qu'on vous l'a dit à tous les
extrémismes les islamistes bien sûr mais
aussi à tous les tenants de toutes les
formes de populisme c'est ce qui a
structuré mon long parcours de
journalistes engagés c'est ce qui a
nourri mon expression
c'est la raison pour laquelle mes
détracteurs sur Amazon
c'est la raison pour laquelle aussi
depuis une trentaine d'années mesdames
et messieurs je n'ai pas eu droit à une
vie normale
la mienne a été jonchée de cadavres
elle a été jeanchée de sang
la mienne a été alimentée de menaces de
mort
ma vie n'est pas celle à laquelle aspire
n'importe quelle paire de famille
mes enfants contrairement aux vôtres
n'ont pas grandi dans une
on peut pas grandi dans un contexte
normal
ils ont grandi avec des policiers
postés parfois 24 heures de sur 24
devant leur domicile comme s'il
s'agissait d'une ambassade
presque
une espèce de citadelle siégé avec un
père accompagné lui-même obligé d'être
accompagné lui-même de perdre du corps
depuis 2003 lors de ses moindres
déplacements
ceux qui même sont obligés de supporter
la vie qui est la mienne car la France
aujourd'hui
car dans la France d'aujourd'hui on ne
peut plus s'exprimer librement
malheureusement
surtout lorsqu'on s'attaque aux
extrémistes et singulièrement lorsqu'on
vise l'islam politique je n'ai pas à
construire ma vie autour des questions
matérielles je vous le dis mais j'ai
consacré celle-ci à défendre des valeurs
universelles et humanistes je n'ai pas
bâti mes relations à travers une logique
de copinage intéressée
ce qui défendent la République ceux qui
défendent la laïcité et ceux qui
rejettent sincèrement l'islamisme sont
tous mes copains pour reprendre
l'expression de votre collègue
et vous comprendrez Mesdames et
Messieurs que certains ne peuvent pas
être mes copains lorsqu'ils ne défendent
pas ces valeurs
et c'est mieux ainsi
lorsque l'année dernière on m'a proposé
pour une décoration je l'ai refusé même
s'il paraît qu'on ne refuse pas une
décoration je l'ai refusé parce que je
n'attends ni récompense ni honneur ni
argent ni aucun privilège en revanche en
revanche mesdames et messieurs
j'exige oui j'exige du respect
j'exige du respect monsieur
similaire à celui que je vous témoigne à
tous
en votre qualité d'élus
en votre qualité de femme et d'hommes
un respect similaire à celui que j'ai
toujours témoigné pour cette république
que vous incarnez et que je n'aurais de
cesse de défendre
merci Monsieur Sifaoui comme vous le
voyez je vous ai laissé un certain temps
je vous remercie monsieur le Président
d'intervention et si je vais vous
accuser d'être dans un copinage et si je
l'ai fait c'est surtout parce que
jusqu'à présent vous n'aviez pas eu
l'occasion de vous exprimer publiquement
sur des sujets ou effectivement vous
avez été mise en cause dès le départ si
je puis dire
je voudrais tout de même avant de passer
à
ce qui nous relie aujourd'hui c'est à
dire cet homme de question précise je
voudrais vous dire et qu'il y a quelques
propos
qui ne peuvent pas fonctionner
l'un de ses propos
ne doit pas se traiter ici il a
l'intérêt d'être
dit publiquement et sur votre ressenti
concernant les propos d'un de nos
collègues de cette de cette mission
parce que les choses peuvent se traiter
autrement
vous avez parlé
de vous avez utilisé le mot on s'attaque
je voudrais être bien au clair sur un
point c'est que cette commission
d'enquête de s'attaque à personne
voilà elle ne s'attaque pas à un
ministre encore au moins un gouvernement
elle établit les faits
elle pose des questions elle écoute les
réponses elle en tire des conclusions
tout ça ce n'est pas s'attaquer
bien entendu je ne crois pas que vous
avez pu entendre qui que ce soit parler
de détournement d'argent pour madame la
ministre
de copinage de manière générale sauf une
citation que vous avez faite
c'est pas notre notre sujet ici
on sait pas attaqué au préfet de Gravel
en rien
moi je respecte apporteur tous les
membres de cette commission respectent
les préfets de la République
on a simplement posé des questions
sur des points de procédure des méthodes
administratives des façons de faire
et des résultats
on est dans notre rôle
et en faisant ça ça n'enlève rien aux
qualités propres de la personne
nous avons toujours considéré qu'il peut
y avoir dans une vie de qualité de
chacun d'entre nous d'ailleurs des
moments où il peut y avoir des erreurs
qui sont commises voilà on a même fait
nous un texte de loi sur cela la prise
en compte
pardon du droit à l'erreur
elle était loin mais voilà
nullobe n'est parfait
et il peut y avoir un moment ou un autre
d'une carrière des difficultés
particulières nous les avons pointés
nous les pointerons dans notre rapport
et c'est tout c'est notre rôle c'est
ensuite administration de Dias qu'elle a
à dire c'était le rapport de
l'Inspection générale de
l'administration des prix de décision
personnelle
qui ne relèvent pas de nous mais en
aucune façon vous pourrez prendre le
script exact de tout ce que nous avons
dit à n'a aucune façon nous ne sommes
dans un système d'attaque de qui que ce
soit
et vous le verrez d'ailleurs dans votre
dans notre audition nous nous
attaquerons pas à vous non plus nous
demanderons à établir des faits nous
questionnerons
et vous nous répondrez aussi précisément
que vous le voudrez
ceci étant dit
je vais démarrer par quelques questions
peut-être monsieur le rapporteur
excusez-moi oui pardon merci monsieur le
Président je veux
pour direr consolider même s'il y en a
pas besoin le propos que vient de tenir
le président Claude Raynal m'associer je
partage la totalité de ce qu'il a dit
et je vais simplement pour la forme
faire de remarques comme je l'ai fait
hier d'ailleurs
à l'issue de du propane productif de la
ministre madame Schiappa il faut pas
confondre les temps les lieux et les
procédures nous sommes ici dans une
commission d'enquête parlementaire en
l'occurrence sénatoriale il y a deux
autres procédures une devant le parquet
national financier il y a une autre
inspection générale de l'administration
moi je porte pas de jugement
j'entends ce que vous ressentez mais
c'est devant ces deux instances je les
appelais ou institution que vous avez à
mon avis à leur faire part de votre
sentiment nous sommes ici dans un temps
de contrôle le plus abouti de
l'action du gouvernement et de la
dépense publique
sur un sujet qui est un sujet
évidemment important on le mesure et je
ne vais je ne mélange pas les gens nous
avons des parcours les uns les autres
qui sont différents des vies différentes
vous l'avez dit faites de haut et de bas
et nous devons ici à cet instant nous
extraire de cette condition dans la
mesure du possible pour établir analyser
comprendre et tenter de bien
identifier la réalité des faits et de
faire émerger la vérité pour tirer les
enseignements que dans le cas de notre
commission d'enquête en tant que
sénateur nous souhaitons livrer dans un
rapport pour qu'il soit évidemment rendu
public à l'attention de toutes celles et
ceux qui ont
eu à connaître en tant qu'acteur mais
également vis-à-vis des français puisque
sur la mission qui est la lutte contre
le combat contre les discours
séparatistes je pense que nous sommes
animés tous de cette volonté de faire
reculer
ces discours séparatistes
merci monsieur le rapporteur nous allons
démarrer évidemment par l'origine du
fond Marianne alors vous l'avez dit
à l'instant vous avez des relations
anciennes avec le préfet Gravel vous
avez dit une quinzaine d'années je pense
que ça ça a pris de la plus de
consistance en avançant évidemment
vous attend associé d'une façon ou d'une
autre aux travaux préparatoires vont
consultant sur certains aspects de sa
création nous savons que vous avez
participé en tant qu'expert sur les
réflexions sur la loi est-ce que ça a
été plus loin ensuite sur la création de
fond Marianne
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Rapporteur avant de répondre juste un
point pour que mon propos soit très
clair j'ai utilisé le on impersonnel je
ne visais aucunement votre commission
d'enquête mais je répondais à l'ambiance
générale afin aussi même si peut-être la
plupart d'entre vous n'ont pas besoin
que vous soyez quand même assez vigilant
par rapport à l'ambiance qui entoure
cette affaire l'ambiance toxique je
dirais qui entoure cette affaire je
ferme la parenthèse nous sommes
parfaitement compris me semble-t-il
alors le contexte
qui m'a amené
à rencontrer le cabinet de Madame la
Ministre Marlène Schiappa et le suivant
d'abord je tiens à vous dire
que depuis les attentats du 11 septembre
j'ai été sollicité de façon régulière
par plusieurs institutions
j'ai répondu toujours favorablement et
bénévolement je tiens à préciser à ce
titre que tout au long de ma carrière je
n'ai jamais bénéficier d'un seul centime
de fonds publics ni sollicité ni agit
d'aucune manière dans un dans une
logique de rémunération et ce jusqu'à
l'année qui intéresse
le sujet que vous traitez
je ne vais pas vous faire le long
parcours de consultation diverses et
variées que ce soit sous le regretté
Jacques Chirac
sous l'ancien président Nicolas Sarkozy
sous le président François Hollande et
évidemment sous l'actuel président
d'Emmanuel Macron
j'ai été reçu à maintes reprises par
plusieurs institutions régaliennes qui
s'intéressent à la thématique qui est la
sienne qui est partout qui est la mienne
mais qui est celle de beaucoup d'autres
personnes qui travaillent sur cette
thématique je n'ai pas été
la seule personne à être consulté
à partir des années 2015-2016 la
pression terroriste
s'étend accentué
la manifestation de ce qu'on a appelé la
menace intérieure le terrorisme
domestique
s'est révélé avec acuité
on a vu que ce que je présageais
malheureusement au début des années 2000
sur le fait que cette évolution allait
donner lieu
incontestablement à des actions
terroristes perpétré par des citoyens
français contre d'autres citoyens
français chose qui était totalement
inaudibles au début des années 2000
je vous le dis trivialement en prenez un
peu pour un cinglé lorsque je disais
qu'il allait avoir des attentats des
décapitations et des gens qui allaient
tirer à la kalachnikov dans les rues de
Paris je l'ai écrit je l'ai dit je l'ai
je l'ai annoncé sur des faits objectifs
à partir de 2015 je me suis dit que la
société a pris conscience mais surtout
des décideurs politiques qui souvent
face à ce sujet de l'Islam politique on
fait preuve sinon de calcul de mes
connaissances voir parfois clairement de
l'acheter politique
2015-2016
donc la situation
malheureuse permet à tout un chacun de
prendre conscience du danger terroriste
il y avait un autre aspect qui n'était
pas du tout traité c'est la question
idéologique de l'islam politique je me
suis donc attelé à partir de 2016 à
travailler inlassablement sur la
question idéologique substrat des lacs
des actions terroristes que nous
subissions
et qui n'était pas véritablement prise
en compte en tant que tel c'est-à-dire
autant la menace terroriste avait
suscité la naissance d'une doctrine
d'État qui s'est manifestée par
évidemment des actions policières de
renseignement et de justice
et où la société civile n'avait pas
grand chose à faire sinon à essayer de
je dirais d'alerter des
sur des comportements sur suspects etc
notamment chez la jeunesse ce qu'on aura
appelé après les signaux faibles la
question idéologique n'était pas du tout
traitée et moi j'ai toujours pensé que
il fallait
imaginer deux choses c'est ériger une
vraie doctrine
anti-islamiste une vraie doctrine
antislamiste c'est-à-dire assumer un
combat idéologique contre l'islam
politique qui nous mène un combat qui
mène un combat à toutes les démocraties
et surtout mettre en place des
mécanismes de prévention de la
radicalisation et des mécanismes de
contre narration notamment sur les
réseaux sociaux
d'autant plus que les mouvements
toxiques les mouvements extrémistes en
touche déployer une propagande
extraordinaire depuis la naissance des
réseaux sociaux et ont pris de cours et
de vitesse
les États et donc la France évidemment
était de ce point de vue là très en
retard à partir de l'année je dirais
permettez-moi de livrer un certain
nombre de détails à l'enquête pénale
donc je ne citerai pas de nom et je
citerai d'autant plus pas de nom que
chaque nom qui sort et soumis
aujourd'hui au lynchage que j'ai au
lynchage médiatique et populiste de
certains courants politiques que j'ai
cité tout à l'heure donc je citerai pas
de nom mais en tout état de cause j'ai
été reçu par un certain nombre de aux
responsables j'ai été reçu avec d'autres
en même temps que d'autres séparément à
plusieurs reprises dans plusieurs
ministères dans plusieurs cabinets par
plusieurs conseillers par plusieurs
personnalités par plusieurs ministres
etc
la question c'était que doit-on faire à
votre avis
pour faire face à cette pression
islamiste qui se manifeste de
différentes façons c'est une question
qui me semble-t-il a été
posée à tous ceux qui travaillent sur ce
sujet qui ont été reçus
à partir de
l'été 2020
à partir de l'été 2020
je après la nomination de Madame Marlène
Schiappa au comme ministre délégué à la
citoyenneté
j'apprends qu'un certain nombre de
c'est d'abord j'apprends qu'un de ces de
ces
collaborateurs de ces de ces conseillers
étaient intéressés de avoir un échange
avec moi un échange intellectuel c'est
je vais appeler le conseiller 1 je leur
ai donné voilà on va l'appeler
conseiller ce conseil 1 je vais rentrer
en contact avec lui à partir du mois de
septembre d'abord par texto ensuite
téléphoniquement ensuite on va se
rencontrer physiquement on va échanger
nous allons faire le constat que
évidemment je m'en faisais aucun doute
j'avais aucun doute sur sac le
défendions les mêmes valeurs les mêmes
idées la République la laïcité etc
cette nécessité de
de d'agir mais surtout j'ai compris une
chose c'est qu'il y avait une traduction
politique à partir de 2020 un vrai
changement de doctrine c'est qui me
d'ailleurs qui qui allait dans le sens
que j'ai toujours défendu c'est que
l'État allait enfin affronter l'islam
politique l'idéologie islamiste et
mettre les moyens politiques pour
répondre à la propagande islamiste de
plus en plus pressante
[Musique]
contre la France contre la République
contre les institutions contre les élus
contre les universitaires contre les
journalistes etc
évidemment lorsque je vois cette
réorientation
de la politique étatique
c'est une chose que j'ai toujours
défendue je décide de la soutenir je la
soutiens d'abord intellectuellement je
la soutiens en tant que que personne
engagée
et j'exprime ce soutien de différentes
façons sur les réseaux sociaux dans mes
publications dans mes émissions télé etc
à partir
de la rentrée 2020 le président de la
République va tenir un discours
important au Mureaux le discours des
Mureaux contre le séparatisme islamiste
et là les choses vont s'accélérer
quelques jours plus tard
l'assassinat du professeur du collège
Conflans-Sainte-Honorine
évidemment l'émotion légitime et
d'une certaine façon
une volonté politique qui était déjà
affichée qui s'accentue à ce moment-là
et qui évidemment
qui est interpelle les pouvoirs publics
à agir très vite concours de
circonstances au moment où la politique
gouvernementale va faire cette
je dirais volonté de de répondre à la
propagande islamiste sur Internet on
découvre deux choses on découvre d'abord
que le crime terroriste qui a quitté la
vie à ce professeur
était lié
de façon directe et matérialisée par la
propagande islamique sur les réseaux
sociaux c'est à dire qu'en 11 jours
ce professeur a été diabolisé en 11
jours on a utilisé le discours
victimaire et en 11 jours seulement
quelqu'un qui n'était pas du tout en
contact avec les gens qui
diabolisaient cette victime
aller passer à l'acte on connaît la
suite donc le constat en fait que
personnellement j'avais porté j'avais
fait j'étais pas le seul évidemment
ce matérialisé par un fait dramatique
deuxième
événement de hasard le 2 ou le 3 octobre
au moment du discours des Mureaux
Christian Gravel est nommé au cipdr
bon à partir de là j'ai trois types de
rencontres
j'ai des rencontres au ministère de
l'Intérieur
et j'ai des rencontres aussi et PDR
avec d'autres mais disons les rencontres
les plus les plus régulières se font
avec le ministère de l'Intérieur le
département de Madame Schiappa notamment
et
Christian Gravel et ça se fait de façon
je dirais concomitante et à partir de là
parce que je sais qu'il y a beaucoup de
choses qui se sont dites
ce que je peux documenter et et
l'enquête pénale démontrera il y a eu
des rencontres régulières à la demande à
la demande encore une fois à la demande
du cabinet de Madame Schiappa je n'ai
jamais sollicité un rendez-vous pour
aller faire des offres de services
les différents conseillers celui que
j'ai appelé conseiller a avec lequel
j'ai une relation très cordiale
aujourd'hui parce que jamais agi de
façon qui pourrait me laisser penser
qu'il y avait
quelque chose de malsain
ces personnes travaillaient pour la
République
le conseiller je dirais 4 que j'avais
rencontré quelques mois plus tard plutôt
au cpdr avant même l'arrivée de
Christian Gravel parce que j'étais aussi
en contact avec le prédécesseur de
Christian Gravel
le conseiller 3
et enfin le conseiller 2 les quatre
conseillers avec lesquels je vais être
en contact de façon régulière entre je
dirais les mois de septembre octobre
novembre décembre janvier
février mars jusqu'à jusqu'au mois
d'avril et tout ce processus se passe
sur deux sujets d'abord des
consultations pour alimenter la ministre
dans le cadre de tout ce qui est
compréhension de la future loi
séparatisme etc enfin de ce qui allait
être la loi séparatisme etc ça c'est
l'alimenter afin qu'elle comprenne quels
étaient les enjeux etc donc ils ont
rencontré un certain nombre de d'acteurs
dont moi-même et ensuite
la demande de leur part une demande de
leur part
disant que il sera intéressé que je
puisse traduire les éléments ou les
idées les pistes que Geoffrey que je
leur proposais mais pour moi je
proposais des pistes des réflexions pour
qu'ils s'en emparent et qu'ils en face
qui veulent à aucun moment je me suis
dit tiens je vais proposer un projet
pour moi
et tout ça à ce stade se fait
gracieusement encore une fois donc à
partir de là une précision parce qu'on
va
essayer de préciser les choses je vous
en prie
vous avez donc vous êtes peu exprimé
oralement mais vous avez tweeté un petit
peu
dans un tweet vous dites ce que vous
venez de rappeler je n'ai pas pris cette
initiative spontanément c'est ce que
vous n'aurez pas de souci
j'y étais encouragé par des
représentants des pouvoirs publics
notamment par les membres du cabinet de
Madame Schiappa c'est ce que je veux
dire je vous le souligne à nouveau
sincèrement aujourd'hui et vous rajoutez
et paraît le même
si vous pouvez un peu nous développer ce
point
les rencontres avec Madame Schiappa
désolé parce que au-delà de la chose et
de sa gravité
je suis quelqu'un d'assez joviable donc
quand des choses me font rire je ris
elle sera pas elle n'est pas mon ami
elle n'a pas été elle est pas
aujourd'hui elle sera encore moins
demain vous savez pourquoi je dis ça je
devais pas le dire je dis ça parce que
je n'aime pas les gens qui n'ont pas de
courage
je ne respecte pas les gens qui n'ont
pas de courage je vous l'ai dit Madame
Schiappa est innocente mais je l'ai dit
deux dès le départ son attitude est
curieuse elle a une attitude de
quelqu'un qui est coupable mais elle est
coupable de rien et je le redis devant
vous et je lui je lui redis c'est pas le
sujet d'ailleurs non nous ne parlons pas
de culpabilité donc elle a une attitude
de coupable c'est moi qui le dis là son
attitude si j'étais un observateur
extérieur de cette affaire je dis tiens
madame Schiappa quelque chose à se
reprocher et c'est bizarre n'a rien à se
reprocher écoutez c'est pas à vous de le
dire devant je vous donne mon sentiment
de votre point de vue voilà mais
revenons au fait vous dites et par
Madame Schiappa donc vous avez été
encouragé par Madame Chapat c'est ce que
vous vous avez dit tout à fait est-ce
que vous le confirmez ou pas et
qu'est-ce comment ça s'est traduit ça
c'est traduit par des rencontres alors
effectivement on s'est rencontré des
rencontres enfin de réunion avec son
cabinet et je vais citer deux rencontres
notamment ou à l'issue de réunion qui
porte sur le projet que nous que j'ai
proposé d'abord que j'ai plus tard
quand un ministre sort pour vous saluer
et pour vous dire je compte sur vous
est-ce que c'est encouragé à mettre en
application un projet ou pas quand les
conseillers de la ministre vous disent
la ministre apprécie énormément le
projet que vous nous avez présenté elle
croit en ce projet elles sont inspirent
énormément
et vous encourage à
le présenter et à le et à le défendre
et il sera regardé avec bienveillance
etc c'est autre chose non mais attendez
troisièmement lorsque à l'issue de
d'une rencontre que je devais avoir avec
elle effectivement le 22 avril
le 22 avril elle devait me recevoir pour
que nous puissions parler de ce projet
en tête-à-tête finalement cette
rencontre a été annulée en raison d'un
agenda compliqué où elle était retenue
je crois avec le président de la
République le Premier ministre de
mémoire elle arrive enfin de rendez-vous
avec son directeur de cabinet monsieur
Sébastien Jallet
elle me salue et elle me dit encore une
fois qu'elle compte sur moi quel compte
sur moi et qu'elle m'encourage vivement
à le mettre en application le plus vite
possible et que ça sera vu étudier etc
alors je mets un bémol et c'est pour ça
que je veux aller vers la précision
c'est vrai qu'à aucun moment ni madame
Schiappa ni son cabinet non pris un
engagement financier à mon égard jamais
jamais
il y a eu deux étapes une étape de d'un
processus de réflexion qui a amené au
projet une présentation par moi-même du
projet
que j'ai finalement décidé parce que je
me suis dit
si j'ai toujours défendu cette idée je
ne vois pas pourquoi je
l'appliquerai pas et la troisième étape
donc de validation politique si j'ose
dire il y a une validation politique de
la part de Madame Schiappa et du cabinet
de Madame Schiappa il restait une
dernière étape c'est de la validation
administrative et financière du projet
donc le projet son état de financement
initial j'ai entendu une histoire de
300.000 euros pour moi ça ça a pas de
sens et je vais vous dire pourquoi ça a
pas de sens ça ne va pas résister à un
examen froid distancié et documenté de
de la chronologie que je vais vous citer
dans le détail ça ne va pas résister
c'est pas possible il y a pas eu on n'a
jamais parlé de 300000 euros jamais
attendez je pense que on va y revenir
moi je voudrais deux enfin je fais une
observation à ce stade
les déclarations que vous faites sur les
discussion ou les rencontres avec Madame
Schiappa
semble-t-il vous confirmer les
déclarations de la ministre hier qui
explique que c'est plutôt et vous l'avez
dit je dis pas entre deux portes mais
c'est assez furtif ça n'est dans aucun
des éléments où vous venez de nous
donner ça n'est pas un entretien d'une
demi-heure une heure où le projet
discuté en tête-à-tête avec des
conseillers ça c'est le premier aimant
mais je voudrais revenir parce que vous
avez dit à partir du 2 octobre monsieur
Gravel est nommé comme secrétaire
général du cpdr et alors il y a de
manière suivie un certain nombre de
d'échanges de rencontre est-ce que vous
pouvez nous communiquer aujourd'hui ou
très rapidement
des preuves de parce que logiquement
vous avez des rendez-vous fixés donc
vous devez
une chronologie des dates et
certainement d'ailleurs avec
l'administration restez-vous de
responsabilité des mails de confirmation
sur ces rencontres parce que à l'heure
actuelle moi je prends note de votre
déclaration d'un certain nombre de
contacts suivi et réguliers avec les
autorités je veux dire comme ça
politique et administratives et j'ai
juste besoin ça nous permet là encore
pour objectiver les faits et les
séquencée dans le temps de bien
comprendre donc si vous pouvez soit tout
de suite soit à l'issue de cette
audition nous faire suivre des éléments
tangibles qui confirment votre
déclaration merci j'ai désolé de de ne
pas pouvoir donner aujourd'hui je
voulais pour tout vous dire je les avais
préparé
au moment où je les avais préparé
avant-hier j'avais toute une
documentation avec laquelle je devais
venir
j'ai reçu une très courtoises de la part
d'instruction et
du représentant du parc de la représente
du parquet et des policiers qui ont
effectivement tous saisis et mis sous CD
tout ce qui concernait enfin tous les
documents que j'avais déjà préparés qui
concernent cette affaire donc il faut
que je puisse
à la fois reconnecter l'ensemble des
éléments l'ensemble des traces
numériques etc et je vous communiquerai
des dates dès que possible par un envoi
mail mais ce que je puis vous ce que je
peux vous dire pardon monsieur le
Président non je crois qu'il faut
maintenant qu'on va continuer à vous
poser des questions et au fur et à
mesure vous allez nous répondre si vous
le voulez bien plutôt qu'être en
réaction à vos propos
on va pas inverser la charge
je suis là pour répondre à vos questions
donc monsieur le rapporteur
lors de
l'édition donc le trajet quand même nous
a
pardon mais décidément pardon lors de
son audition le préfet Gravel nous a
rapporté dans son propos que vous avez
dû donc vous avez dû prendre
connaissance que il avait appris que
l'USSE ppm dans laquelle vous avez un
rôle et une fonction pourrait bénéficier
d'un
soutien via le fond Marianne à l'issue
de l'appel téléphonique où j'ai vu avec
lui en disant que vous sortiez du
cabinet de la ministre et que vous lui
aviez parlé du fond Marianne en lui
faisant comprendre que à la fois par
votre statut votre application et votre
investissement ce que vous avez évoqué
il avait selon le dire que vous avez
que nous a rapporté le préfet Gravel
toute sa place dans le fond Marianne et
à ce moment-là nous sommes en amont
évidemment de la mise en place du format
Marianne qui n'interviendra que le 20
avril
est-ce que c'est bien la réunion que
vous avez
évoqué à quel moment
est-ce que vous avez la date précise
est-ce que vous avez contacté
à ce sujet le préfet grabel et ce qu'il
vous avait d'ailleurs signifier à
quelconque engagement
certains très probables ou au contraire
très évasif
alors ce que vous a dit le préfet Gravel
est vrai mais je mettrai quelques un
bémol et quelques nuances de précision
je dois vous avouer qu'au départ la
question m'a été posée par
les inspecteurs de l'IGA honnêtement
j'avais oublié cet épisode c'est un peu
en recherchant
à la fois dans ma mémoire et essayant de
remettre la chronologie que j'ai fait
j'ai réétabli y compris par
une certaine chronologie on pense bête
un petit peu par écrit
je me suis remémoré la chose suivante la
Réunion cabinet de Madame Schiappa où
elle vient me saluer à l'issue et pas
entre deux portes ou en échange un petit
quart d'heure 10 minutes un quart
d'heure à vous d'apprécier ce qu'on peut
veut se dire en 10 minutes un quart
d'heure
on me dit la chose suivante
on me dit membre du cabinet les membres
du cabinet et ensuite madame Schiappa me
disent la chose suivante
il y a un fond un fond on me parle pas
du fond Marianne on me parle d'un fond
qui sera dédié qui va être mobilisé en
me donne pas de montant un fond
important qui sera dédié aux contre
discours et qui sera mis en place assez
vite et qu'ils attendaient les derniers
arbitrages selon votre mémoire c'est à
quelle date le 24 mars
très précisément
et donc à l'échu
enfin parce que ça m'a été dit à la fin
de la réunion
je n'ai pas réagi sur le coup
je parle de fond en parlant me parle
d'un fond voilà par l'info pour ce qui
me ce qui me fait plaisir si j'ose dire
c'est la détermination je sens une
détermination chez les politiques
c'est là où les gens sont parfois et je
compte sur vous pour prendre de la
hauteur par rapport à cette affaire
on essaie de s'y employer
je vois que vous vous accordez confiance
poursuivez je vois que vous vous donnez
beaucoup de mal et je suis certain que
vous y arriverez
je me dis pas youpi je vais toucher de
l'argent enfin c'est complètement
ridicule le penser je me dis c'est super
l'État a enfin compris qu'il fallait
dégager le nerf de la guerre pour
pouvoir répondre au système je vous
rappelle je vous rappelle la chose
suivante c'est que l'islam politique
n'est pas générée par des gens
éparpillés ici et là ce ne sont pas des
individus
ce sont pas des jeunes alors cela on
sait de répondre qui sont dans les
quartiers populaires
il y a des étapes parfois derrière oui
mais ceux qui finance le discours
toxique islamiste c'est le Qatar c'est
parfois des alliés de la France c'est la
Turquie qui est membre de l'OTAN pardon
pardon
politique le contexte monsieur le
Président non il est important de
comprendre ok croyez croyez qu'ici nous
le connaissons je me dis je me dis tout
simplement qu'un fond dédié à sa contre
discours est une décision politique sur
ce j'appelle Christian Gravel voilà et
je lui dis
mais croyant qu'il était au courant
en disant c'est une très bonne nouvelle
de cette mobilisation du fond et il me
dit je ne suis pas au courant il me dit
que vous donc il vous fait cette réponse
donc vous là vous êtes sur la même
version que les propos du préfet Gravel
qui n'ont pas été complètement confirmés
par la ministre mais ça c'est juste pour
la clarté je pense que la ministre a des
problèmes de mémoire ce qui peut arriver
c'est pour la clarté du débat moi ce que
je veux dire avant le 24 mars vous
l'avez dit vous avez eu un certain
nombre de contacts et vous aurez
l'occasion très rapidement de nous
donner les temps les modalités et donc
finalement
les échanges que vous avez pour à la
fois
nourrir le débat et les projets que vous
devez avoir en tête parce que on est au
24 mars mais très rapidement quand même
vous allez déposer un projet ambitieux
porté par une association
dont vous faites partie donc ça veut
dire que les éléments constitutifs de
votre réflexion éventuellement de votre
projet vous voyez
où vous devinez qu'elles vont devenir
qu'ils vont devenir tangibles à travers
un projet une ambition du gouvernement
dans laquelle vous allez vous souhaiter
et vous allez vous inscrire c'est bien
ça c'est bien ça c'est à dire que je
vois que le projet qui est né à l'issue
de plusieurs
le point de départ c'est le 24 mars
avant il y a d'autres réunions mais là
il se passe quelque chose il y a une
autre réunion qui a priori se tient
début avril le 6 avril en votre présence
en votre présence pardon le préfet
Gravel est un conseiller
chargé des relations avec les élus les
collectivités
quel était à ce stade le l'objet est de
cette réunion sont contenus est-ce que
des éléments nouveaux plus précis sur
le fond un appel à projet à ce moment-là
sont abordés avec vos interlocuteurs
lors de merci monsieur le rapporteur
lors de la réunion du 6 avril on ne
parle pas de fond on parle que du projet
on ne parle que du projet de quel projet
parce que celui qui sera qui sera non
parce que pardon mais le 24 mars vous
dites on vous a évoqué
l'arrivée possible d'un fond sans plus
donc je pense que le 6 avril vous allez
un peu plus loin
c'est la raison pour laquelle je vous
dis quel est le contenu quel est l'objet
est-ce que on vous donne plus d'éléments
non absolument pas on ne le 6 avril on
ne parle que du projet le projet que je
dois incarner à ce moment-là il y avait
besoin d'affiner un certain nombre
d'éléments encore une fois à ce
moment-là je leur propose je le
représente aucun chiffre
jusqu'au 24 mars je le propose aucun
chiffrage je parle d'un chiffrage
je ne propose aucun chiffrage d'accord
je suis très
précisé donc on va chiffrer pardon avec
Monsieur caronagara on va chiffrer le
projet entre le 24 mars et le 6 avril
voilà d'accord non mais c'est pour ça
que je dis jusqu'au 24 mars notre projet
est un projet intellectuel une méthode
j'avais bien compris donc le 6 avril
puisqu'il est le premier temps du 24
mars donc le 6 avril c'est pour ça que
je vous demandais quel est l'objet ce
que vous livrez un contenu est-ce que
vous avez des échanges vous avez une
première approche je dirais systémique
stratégique
documentée avec un projet de
financement des une ébauche d'enveloppes
je donne le d'abord le 6 avril La
Réunion porte sur
le projet en lui-même la stratégie et
pardon le jour de l'ouverture de votre
commission d'enquête j'ai vu qu'avait
fuité un des documents qui est dans le
dossier la fameuse fiche synthétique le
projet la subvention n'a pas été donnée
à par rapport à cette fiche synthétique
c'est faux cette fiche synthétique si
ceux qui l'ont commenté avaient fait un
minimum preuve d'un minimum de
professionnalisme il aurait fallu juste
aller voir la constitution du dossier
que vous avez la constitution du dossier
le jour de l'appel à projet et dans
cette constitution de du dossier figuré
deux documents qu'on devait renseigner
une fiche détaillée du projet et une
fiche synthétique la fiche synthétique
devait faire un feuillet c'est à dire
synthétiser c'est en bon français
synthétique c'est synthétique mais c'est
vous qui venez avec ces éléments et ça
fait l'objet de la discussion non non
c'est moi je viens avec un projet de
d'une dizaine de pages
et avec un bloc-notes dans lequel
j'avais noté toutes les idées etc je
vais pas vous alourdir sauf si vous le
souhaitez présente le projet dans le
détail ça prend à peu près une heure
vous présentez le projet vous vous
quittez en bon terme et sur le chiffrage
pardon sur le chiffrage je précise une
chose c'est que moi je dis dès le départ
il n'y a absolument aucun intérêt à
financer un projet qui ne soit pas pluri
annuel et dont on n'est pas sûr de la
pérennité par conséquent à partir du 24
avril
on travaille avec Cyril car on a garant
suivez comme l'a dit le président on va
rester sur le 24 mars pardon
[Musique]
pour moi entre le 24 mars et le 6 avril
nous avons travaillé avec Cyril
caronaguarra sur chiffrage
d'un projet plus réaluel au départ on
devait chiffrer simplement
dit mais voilà je ferais bien on va
commencer à travailler c'est ce que je
vous dis moi je suis responsable de mon
propos après vous savez dans ce genre
d'audition dans ce genre d'exercice des
gens peuvent oublier être imprécis etc
je vous le redis encore une fois nous
avons travaillé sur le chiffrage d'un
projet plus réannuel et nous avons
établi ensemble c'est lui qui a fait qui
a renseigné des éléments techniques
c'est à dire le bilan prévisionnel sur
trois ans
et le chiffrage complet sur trois ans
montrez que le projet sur trois années
coûte aller coûter un million 500000
euros pourquoi un million 500 000 euros
ça peut faire hurler parce que tout
simplement la riposte sur Internet
nécessite la mobilisation de moyens
humains qui dit moyen humain dit moyen
humain pas seulement l'expression
Seigneur c'est à dire des gens confirmés
c'est pas avec des juniors ou des
débutants qu'on peut faire la riposte à
l'islamisme par conséquent il faut des
salaires qui disent salaires donc on
avait imaginé une petite armada de
personnes capable de répondre sur
internet si vous raison pour laquelle si
vous voulez bien sûr
trois ans pour une précision le
ce document je l'ai sur trois ans
il était question
une première année
je pense qu'on va à 635000 euros
par contre donc nous sommes le 6 avril
vous avez donc vous venez avec votre
projet vous quittez je pense en bon
terme et j'imagine qu'on vous dit
quelque chose
on est en train de on est en train
d'étudier le projet
très sérieusement alors attendez et
quand j'ai besoin parce que je veux le
mot projet il peut pas être utilisé dans
tous les sens donc vous sortez vous
quittez forcément je le devine en bons
termes et on vous dit quoi ben écoutez
on va regarder maintenant on va prendre
votre dossier et regarder comment il
s'inscrit dans la durée on va étudier
votre projet un projet monsieur le
rapporteur vous allez projeter
vous allez comprendre pourquoi
j'essaie d'être méthodique donc vous
sortez alors il s'avère donc le
lendemain
est évoqué l'idée d'un appel à projet à
l'initiative du Gouvernement sur lequel
le gouvernement réfléchit donc je
conclus de ce que vous venez de me dire
que le 6 avril veille du 7
ou sera évoqué l'idée d'un appel à
projet vous n'avez eu aucune information
d'un d'une possible démarche
initié par le gouvernement de lancer un
appel à projet sur cette thématique
absolument pas d'accord absolument pas
je n'ai aucune information le laissant
croire que le gouvernement allait faire
un appel au projet d'accord donc à ce
stade monsieur le rapporteur si vous
permettez à ce stade
le 6 avril je parle au nom d'une
association
je parle au nom d'une association qui
porte un projet validé politiquement
et qui est en train de discuter avec des
pouvoirs publics quant à sa réalisation
nous l'avons ni appel à projet je suis
pas au courant encore et le projet
puisqu'il est porté me dites-vous par
une association j'imagine qu'il a fait
l'objet de débat avec les membres de
l'association le bureau et qui a un
compte rendu de validation de ce projet
qui va être peut-être soutenu par le
gouvernement moi j'ai tenu au courant
les différents les quelques membres
qu'il y a dans l'association
ou avec du formalisme il y a eu un
formalisme mais
un conseil d'administration d'accord
avec un compte rendu conseil
d'administration
il vous semble vous êtes sûr non mais je
pense que oui
que moi mais je ne réalisais pas vous ne
réalisez pas
nous a expliqué qu'il avait travaillé
24/24 du 7 au 9 c'est pour ça non mais
du Châteauneuf c'est autre chose on a
parlé on a parlé de de du projet à
partir du mois de janvier et donc le 6
je finis cette ce rendez-vous le 7 je
reçois un email du conseiller 3
et le conseiller 3
m'envoie une série de documents
me disant au sujet de votre projet
merci de renseigner l'ensemble de ces
documents et les transmettre aussi PDR
sur ce et vous avez 48 heures pour le
faire s'il vous plaît alors j'y viens
tout de suite
vous voyez il y a une
bonne articulation donc
deux questions sur le travail avec le
cpdr et son secrétaire général à
plusieurs reprises il a été évoqué que
vous étiez d'ailleurs formateur
au sein et vous l'avez
sous-entendu voir dit assez clairement
au sein de l'unité de ce que le
gouvernement appelle le contre discours
républicain
pouvez-vous me dire nous dire qui vous a
sollicité pour réaliser ces formations
et à partir de quand
les aveux vous dispensés
étiez-vous d'ailleurs rémunéré soit
personnellement soit au titre d'une
structure d'entreprise ou
associative jusque jusqu'à quelle
période avez-vous
dispensé ces formations et est-ce que
avec le cpdr vous avez d'autres actions
voire même d'autres actions ayant donné
lieu à des rémunérations bon on va
revenir un peu quelques quelques mois en
arrière donc on est en avril on revient
en octobre
lorsque Monsieur Gravel est nommé aussi
PDR je vous l'ai dit j'étais déjà en
contact avec son son
prédécesseur j'avais aussi quelques
contacts au sein du cpdr je suis grave
elle m'appelle avec d'autres et nous
propose de constituer un comité
scientifique première étape et
de ce que je me souviens il me dit j'ai
besoin du soutien de tout le monde parce
que je suis chargé de mettre en place
très vite unité de contrôle de contre
discours républicains et je n'ai pas les
moyens humains suffisants en tout cas de
la ressource qui maîtrise la matière
lors de discussions soit en groupe avec
les autres personnes sollicitées soit en
bilatérale il m'a demandé s'il pouvait
compter sur mon aide je parle en une
première étape sur mon aide je lui ai
assuré qu'il pouvait compter sur mon
aide entre le 2 octobre le jour de soul
le lendemain de sa nomination jusqu'à
novembre j'ai agi de façon bénévole
auprès du cpdr au quotidien
au quotidien le 24 ou le 25 octobre il
m'a appelé pour me dire que la ministre
délégué à la citoyenneté et lui-même
souhaité que je prenne par un voyage
officiel déplacement officiel dans le
Tarn à Albi pour participer à un
séminaire ce qu'on appelle les clients
donc le 26 octobre nous sommes rendus
madame Schiappa Tristan Gravel et
moi-même
Albi pour assurer cette journée de
séminaire et ensuite madame Schiappa que
vous avez c'est peut-être un détail vous
avez voyagé ensemble non moi vous savez
je suis en train j'ai mes contraintes
que j'ai citées de façon rapide dans
l'introduction donc je voyage dans des
conditions qui sont gérées par le
ministère de l'Intérieur et selon
je comprends bien les contrats en
question donc
le lendemain nous avons tous les trois
participer à cette journée de séminaire
et Madame Schiappa poursuivi sa visite
ministérielle et nous sommes nous sommes
rentrés et j'ai continué mes relations
avec le cpdr on a entamé un début je
dirais d'échanges intellectuels et
encore une fois c'est sol était
quotidienne
et je ne m'en plains pas c'était j'étais
j'étais totalement je dirais disposer
vers la mi-novembre Christian Gravel m'a
fait savoir qu'il était gêné par le fait
de me solliciter au quotidien et qui
comptait sur mon application et que je
serai de toute façon rémunéré et qu'il a
eu la corde de la ministre d'accord et
ça donc cela a fait l'objet d'un devis
et d'une facture en bonne et due forme
qui qui était me semble-t-il parce que
je sache maintenant après il faut voir
comment fonctionne cette administration
et comment fonctionne ce gouvernement on
n'a pas fait ça je vous le rassure au
sous-sol d'un café dans le 20e
arrondissement on a fait ça dans des
ministères en bonne et due forme avec
des sociétés qui existent
toutes les institutions régaliennes
pardon
toutes les institutions régaliennes a
commencé par la présidence de la
République a commencé par le ministre
ministère le cabinet du ministre de
l'Intérieur a commencé par la le cabinet
de Madame Schiappa savait que j'étais
totalement impliqué et que je reconnais
les équipes de Lucie vous avez commencé
à bénéficier de rémunération à partir de
la le devis a été établi fin octobre
OK et ça a été fait en nom propre au nom
d'une association ou d'une entreprise
merci juste un mot ça couvrait quelle
période ça couvrait alors c'était un
forfait et ce forfait payable en une
fois qui devait durer initialement une
année je l'ai fait durer jusqu'au
jusqu'à janvier 2023
janvier 2023
c'est un forfait mais qui a été payé en
plusieurs fois puisque c'était une
nature à venir non plus une fois c'est
un forfait payé en une fois oui mais pas
comment ça se passe plusieurs mois
généralement quand vous délivrez une
facture à l'administration au mois de
mois de novembre décembre vous êtes payé
3 4 5 mois plus tard de mémoire donc si
vous on est preneur de je dirais de la
trace de ce document si vous voulez bien
verrez avec la police judiciaire
d'accord tout est à son niveau je voilà
merci je voulais juste m'assurer je mon
esprit
non pas embrumé mais un peu confus le 24
mars la réunion se tient
en votre présence et en présence de
membres du cabinet
et du préfet Gravel où le préfet Gravel
24 mars il n'était pas il était il était
le 6 avril sinon je l'aurais pas appelé
après pour lui dire que je sors du
cabinet d'accord
dernière sur le les contacts avec le CPD
recense culture générale quand avez-vous
discuté pour la première fois avec les
membres enfin le secrétaire général
plutôt du projet de l'essai ppm
parce que vous avez bien parlé de votre
projet que j'appellerai
dans l'idée dans la stratégie et comme
les jours chaque jour compte
le 9 avril Cyril karunagaran envoie le
le projet chiffré aussi PDF à la demande
du cabinet
à partir de là pour une question
d'organisation et pour tout vous dire
moi je n'aime pas c'est pas je suis pas
très attiré par les questions
administratives et la gestion de ces
aspects là donc on s'est répartis les
rôles de façon très claire c'est que
Cyril devait garder d'être
l'interlocuteur du cpdr et moi je devais
il a plutôt une formation très
à l'aise sur les questions
administratives il est très allé sur les
questions administratives voilà pour
tout vous dire il nous a pas vraiment
dit qu'il était parfaitement à l'aise
sur les sujets administratifs et
financiers mais
comme vous formez aussi un binôme assez
proche je voulais juste vous dire qu'il
y a pas de j'ai pas de sujet j'ai pas
compris j'ai pas compris votre remarque
j'ai pas entendu je pense que vous
l'avez compris je vais vous la reformer
la même manière mais pourquoi vous
préjugés ce que je raconte on est dans
un rapport dans un échange cordial
pourquoi vous vous matrez
à la fois cordiale et courtois je reste
donc cordial et courtois mais par
honnêteté parce que moi je n'aime pas
les choses trap et je préfère s'il y a
un point de désaccord on l'identifie
madame la ministre hier m'a fait répéter
deux fois la même question et même la
deuxième fois elle m'a expliqué qu'elle
ne comprenait pas soit j'ai un langage
abscon mais en général on dit je suis
plutôt assez direct voilà c'est tout
mais je vous dis que le Président nous a
déclaré ne pas être habitué à porter des
dossiers de type d'organisation de
budgétisation etc et ce qui n'est pas
très au fait c'est nous l'a dit lui-même
juge je vous le rappelle très bien voilà
je vous ai dit qui était à l'aise sur la
question administrative je vous ai pas
dit qu'il était spécialiste de la
gestion des subventions c'est vrai qu'il
n'avait jamais demandé une subvention en
revanche Cyril et à l'aise pour faire
des bilans prévisionnels pour beaucoup
plus à l'aise avec moi avec les tableaux
sur les tableaux Excel donc nous ne
disons pas des choses contradictoires
c'est peut-être votre lecture qui vous
amène à avoir des choses contractées je
vous laisse voilà non mais ça peut
arriver monsieur
je pense qu'on aura un pointera ensemble
effectivement des contradictions mais
nous on est on essaie aussi le plus
posément possible de de faire la lumière
et de de trouver le fil et le chemin de
la vérité finalement pour pourquoi vous
êtes vous à ce stade en quelques jours
tournés vers le seppm pour finalement
porter le projet de fond Marianne
puisque c'était pas à ma connaissance
vraiment l'objet de ces associations
quel lien il y avait vous trouvez
quels étaient d'ailleurs jusqu'à ce
moment-là les objectifs
portés par cette association je vous
remercie quand
la discussion a lieu au cabinet
au départ je ne c'est vrai que j'informe
Cyril très tôt
je crois de même des descentes
mais dans mon esprit c'est pas acté je
veux dire c'est pas acté que ça soit lu
à seppm qui qui va porter le projet
je laisse le choix au membre du cabinet
je leur dis je suis en contact avec
plusieurs associations je leur cite
quatre ou cinq associations
et je cite lui seppm dans sa
dénomination complète
l'Union des fédérations des sociétés
d'éducation physique et de préparation
au service militaire ça fait sourire
tout le monde
il demande qu'est-ce que c'est que ça je
dis c'est une vieille association d'où
ça domination 1885 sa naissance et elle
est reconnue d'utilité publique
tout le monde s'est arrêté sur cette
reconnaissance d'utilité publique ah bon
allez reconnaître l'utilité publique je
dis oui
et j'y suis depuis quelques temps
ils me disent très bien on va voir et on
vous dit voilà mais ça serait une bonne
idée qu'est-ce qu'elle fait je dis elle
fait ça donc j'explique un peu son
historique et j'explique que depuis 2016
2017 il y a eu au sein de l'association
et une réorientation sur les questions
de prévention la radicalisation j'ai
entendu des commentaires en disant oui
mais c'est pas l'objet etc lorsque cette
association est née à la fin du 19e
siècle et que ces statues ont été
réactualisés je crois début du 20e
reconnaissance d'utilité publique depuis
on est dans un contexte historique
d'aucun connaissent on parle d'armée la
jeunesse
physiquement c'est à dire c'était une
association qui préparait les enfants
des petits bourgeois à aller à la guerre
bon
je pense que si on devait dire
aujourd'hui qu'il faut réarmer la
société intellectuellement et réarmée et
armée la jeunesse pour qu'elle fasse
face pour qu'elle fasse
qu'elle fasse
je dirais barage intellectuellement
et qu'elle devienne hermétique à la
propagande islamiste ce n'est pas
contradictoire donc après on peut avoir
une discussion mais cette discussion
pardon je vais vous le dire je vais pas
l'avoir ici en ce qui me concerneaux
lorsque c'est un débat juridique c'est
tout c'est un débat juridique
d'interprétation de toutes les lois de
toutes les associations sur la loi 1901
juste s'il vous plaît voilà donc
2016-2017 vous venez de dire vous
réorientez puisque vous êtes je
comprends à ce moment-là déjà membre de
l'association à ce moment-là vous
modifiez l'objet de
les activités de l'association
puisqu'elle est reconnue d'utiliser
public il y a là aussi des modifications
des comptes rendus qui en attestent oui
non oui on en a parlé je sais que il y a
des comptes-rendus et des assemblées
générales qui ont évité le sujet je sais
que Cyril lorsqu'il a pris la présidence
je dirais traiter ce sujet c'est à quel
moment qu'il 2016-2017 le problème qui
s'est posé c'est que toute 2016-2017
vous dit 2016-2017 si j'avais si je
savais que c'était le 24 octobre 2016
vous l'aurais dit mais 2016-2017
je reprends l'expression exacte qui a
été utilisé par des avocats c'est ouvrir
une usine à gaz que d'essayer de refaire
les statuts d'une association qui est
déjà reconnue d'utilité publique
c'est-à-dire que ils ont expliqué que
vous perdez la reconnaissance d'utilité
publique et que c'est très compliqué etc
etc bon d'accord je suis pas là pour le
coup spécialiste des questions
administratives sur
sur les associations
alors dans les documents dont on dispose
il est indiqué que vous êtes
salarié de l'uspm dans le cadre de la
réalisation du projet du fond Marianne
premièrement y a-t-il une compatibilité
juridique entre cette situation de
salarié et les statuts de l'association
puisque vous avez également et je le
signale indiqué au secrétaire général du
cpdr que vous alliez démissionner du
conseil administration l'avez-vous fait
si vous l'avez fait ça s'est matérialisé
de quelle manière et à quelle date
j'avais entre l'année 2020 et le début
de l'année 2021 j'étais trésoriée j'ai
démissionné du poste de trésorier des
février donc 2020 il faudra qu'on
regarde la date à partir du moment où
vous êtes trésorier vous devenez salarié
absolument pas non mais d'accord
jusqu'au 24 avril jusqu'au 24 mai parmi
pour le compte du projet
ilaique je n'avais jamais été salarié ni
je me suis fait rembourser ni j'ai y
compris sur des frais que j'ai engagé
pour le compte de l'usupère jamais
la question de la rémunération est liée
au fait que je devais m'impliquer
complètement dans le projet que je
devais laisser un certain nombre
d'activités et pardon laissez-moi
sourire un petit peu aussi là aussi
c'est que le côté ridicule quelques mois
auparavant je lance un projet personnel
à haut potentiel financé financier
d'accord qui n'a besoin du soutien de
personnes avec un partenaire
suffisamment solide je le mets entre
parenthèses pour aller faire un signé un
pathétique contrat à 4422 euros brut
pour toucher au final autour de 3200
euros net donc net imposable donc à un
moment donné le ridicule il faut pas
qu'il tue j'ai 35 ans de vie
professionnelle 56 ans je ne pense pas
qu'il soit scandaleux que je sois
rémunéré à cette hauteur maintenant sur
la compatibilité entre la rémunération
et leur statut d'administrateur puisque
des journalistes peu informer mal
informés qui se prennent pour des
travailler des et qui supplantes
intellectuellement la connaissance que
peuvent avoir des avocats spécialisés
dans le droit du travail il aurait fallu
juste consulter peut-être un spécialiste
du droit du travail et leur expliquer la
chose suivante c'est que la rémunération
d'un administrateur est possible
lorsqu'il s'agit de rémunérer une
mission spécifique et non pas sa
fonction d'administrateur c'est qui ce
qui était mon cas donc il n'y a
absolument très bien de contradiction
j'avais demandé à Cyril si je devais
totalement démissionner de l'association
il m'a dit que non m'a dit que non et
par conséquent je suis resté
administrateur et j'ai accepté de
remplir dans le cadre d'un contrat de
travail qui a été signé en bonne et due
forme d'accord donc puisque vous parlez
des administrateurs dans la liste de
ceci
qui nous a été communiqué dans le
dossier de candidature en fait
la liste des administrateurs ne
correspondait pas à la liste qui était
enregistrée en préfecture est-ce que
vous en aviez est-ce que vous avez
connaissance de divergence non d'accord
je l'ai appris que récemment
quand est-ce que vous avez évoqué pour
la première fois
l'uspm votre association
auprès
des autorités auxquelles vous aviez à
faire c'est à dire soit le cabinet de la
ministre soit le secrétariat général
le cap j'ai évoqué le j'ai évoqué je
n'avais jamais évoqué le nom de
l'association à Christian Gravel j'ai
évoqué le nom de l'association avec le
cabinet et à l'issue je crois que je
l'ai évoqué à deux reprises une fois en
mars
mais début mars
dans une rencontre informelle qui
n'était pas dans le cadre des des autres
rencontres j'avais dit que j'étais voilà
lié à mais je l'ai dit à un des
conseillers mais là où j'en ai parlé
avec précision c'est lors de la réunion
du 6 avril
par la suite Christian Gravel a
découvert me semble-t-il encore une fois
l'existence de l'ufpm lorsque l'uspm a
envoyé le dossier de candidature
le 9 le 9 avril au soir en fin
d'après-midi
et je précise lorsqu'on nous a envoyé le
lorsqu'on m'a envoyé lorsqu'un un des
conseillers
conseiller 3 envoyer le mail avec les
documents renseignés il m'a bien
expliqué qu'il avait que nous avions
deux jours pour enseigner le et que il
fallait absolument que le dossier soit
envoyé au plus tard vendredi en fin
d'après-midi
ceci fait oui
vous nous avez un peu déjà répondu à la
question
un moment donné dans les discussions
on en arrive finalement à dire il faut
présenter un dossier vous encourage à
présenter un dossier vous proposez un
dossier et à un moment donné vous avez
une discussion sur l'association et vous
nous dites
vous avez proposé trois quatre
structures d'associatif potentiellement
pouvant faire c'est ce que vous nous
avez dit on est bien d'accord
donc ça veut dire de manière très simple
que à un moment donné le cabinet vous
dit vous ne pouvez pas prendre l'action
j'allais dire en nom personnel bon ça
aurait pu s'imaginer contractuellement
bon mais on souhaite en fait non pas
travailler avec l'association on en
connaît aucune des quatre
c'est pas le sujet c'est on veut
travailler avec vous et donc
l'association servira à porter apporter
l'action quel que soit ses éventuels
compétences donc c'est ça le sujet le
sujet c'est que l'appel à candidature
qui va venir derrière même si on vous le
présente pas encore c'est un appel en
tout cas vers des structures et donc il
faut que ce sont des associations qui
répondent et c'est pour cela que vous
répondez avec le SS on est d'accord on
est absolument d'accord avec une
précision sur les quatre associations
que je cite 3 était totalement connu du
cabinet
ah pardon et donc refuser par refuser
la seule qui connaissait pas je d'une
certaine façon c'est pour ça que je me
sens trahi aujourd'hui je me sens trahi
par les mensonges je me sens trahi par
les approximations et je me sens trahi
par la politique de l'amnésie qui est
menée dans ce dossier
encore une fois je rappelle je n'ai pas
sollicité de subvention on m'a sollicité
je rappelle que l'association j'ai cité
plusieurs associations je les ai laissés
choisir l'association pour les amener
dans une logique de coopération en est
on est censé être comme on pourrait pas
permettre moi l'expression dans un même
bateau donc on est en confiance avec qui
souhaitez-vous que je travaille que je
mette en application ce projet il y a je
connais un thème je connais un tel je
connais un tel non non un tel celui-là
non c'est quoi ça ça c'est voilà et ça
s'est passé comme ça ça c'est pas passé
autrement ça s'est passé comme ça toute
une autre toute autre récit et mensonger
je le dis
que celui-ci d'autres non la question
qui était posée c'est pourquoi cette
association vous donnez la réponse voilà
mais il faut pas voir du mal partout
pardon
d'écrire des faits alors
vous savez que les gens qui regardent
n'ont pas tous votre intelligence pardon
c'est pas il faut pas qu'il vaut que les
gens voient du mal partout de la
connaissance oui c'est plus de la
connaissance voilà donc dans ce cas
précis aussi voilà restons sur les fils
sur les policiers
publics voilà qui les intéresse c'est
quand ils ont bloqué sur la
reconnaissance d'utilité publique voilà
et c'était le seul critère finalement
qui a permis de dire cela d'ailleurs a
été a été dit par par un des deux préfet
semble-t-il on peut retrouver quelque
chose autour cette notion effectivement
d'intérêt public mais on est bien
d'accord en réalité il y a un appel à
projet de pour des structures dans votre
cas particulier on souhaite travailler
avec vous vous n'avez pas de structure
vous reposez quelques structures qui
peuvent accueillir cette action et le
ministère en choisit une voilà
on est d'accord bien
d'ailleurs le préfet Gravel lorsqu'il a
il a dit les choses il a déclaré au
sujet de subvention qu'elle payait de
l'intelligence
c'était
comment dire une expression très
favorable à votre endroit elle payait de
l'intelligence je pense pas qu'il est
dit dans ce dans cet esprit pardon
monsieur le Président
que ce soit dans cette association une
autre on produit de l'intellect et je
continue et d'abord de la production
intellectuelle donc je vais pas laisser
finir ma phrase donc c'est de la
production intellectuelle et une des
questions qui vient derrière c'était
donc est-ce que cette subvention a
constitué en quelque sorte un levier de
financement pour un travail de
consultant alors
si cette question a été posée ainsi
c'est parce qu'on n'avait pas d'abord
l'information que vous venez
que par ailleurs les activités que vous
meniez sur demande
quotidienne avez-vous dit du cpdr était
elle-même déjà rémunéré par un contrat
de consultant
enfin cette partie en fait le contrat en
question le
devis qui a été
élaboré
prévoit un travail de
consulting prévoir en français de
consultants de consultants à prévoir un
travail de formation et prévoit un
travail de d'une certaine façon de
proposition de proposition de contenu
donc et ça ça a duré entre
je dirais les mois d'octobre jusqu'au
mois de mars à peu près l'ensemble après
on uniquement sur la partie formation ok
peu importe peu importe vous nous dites
vous nous avez dit que jusqu'en janvier
2023 vous aviez un contrat de consultant
que ce soit de la formation que ce soit
autre chose etc et dans le cadre je vais
le formuler donc du coup
la question
consentait bien quand même un lien
forcément parce que je veux dire
travailler aller à Albi excellent tout
ça ça a des coûts bon voilà toute
rigueur ça a des coups bon donc il y
avait bien quelque chose de cette nature
et puis imaginer que le contrat que vous
avez passé avec l'association couvrait
cette activité Consulting vous avez dit
préalablement à la question non
l'activité de consultant elle est
jusqu'en janvier 2023
financé par un contrat propre alors du
coup ça amène à une deuxième question
que vous voyez arriver vous dans le le
nouveau contrat avec cette association
vous avez donc une rémunération qui est
qualifiée de rémunération à temps plein
rémunération temple et en même temps
vous avez un contrat de consultant pour
la même période
dans l'ubiquité capacité à faire
plusieurs choses à la fois
comment vous faites là vous avez à la
fois un 35 heures qui n'est pas d'accord
décrit comme un 35 heures mais comme
comment dire une action permanente
avec
l'association et en même temps contrat
de consultants qui portent sur certains
aspects particuliers si je puis dire la
formation etc avec le CPL est-ce que
vous pouvez nous expliquer comment on
peut avoir la juxtaposition de ces deux
contrats
ceux qui ont travaillé avec moi
à différentes époques
vont comprendre ce que je vais vous dire
j'ai une capacité de travail qui est
bien supérieure
à la normale
par passion par
je dirais intérêt intellectuel pour la
matière
et une époque où je réalisais des
reportages et j'écrivais des articles
tout en rédigeant mes livres le soir
donc je suis quelqu'un qui travaille
énormément
je n'ai je veux pas ouvrir une autre
polémique politique je n'ai jamais cru
que des gens de mon profil puissent se
suffire d'être 35 heures donc je
travaille pas 35 heures je travaille pas
40 je travaille beaucoup plus mais
weekend sont très rares bien et soirée
sont plutôt je vous rassure nous aussi
non ce que ça rassure surtout ce qui
vous ont élu j'espère bien voilà restons
sur la question mais restons sur la
question et surtout voyez-vous sous
l'angle de l'administration on est
toujours là dedans bon vous avez vous
vous avez deux contrats en même temps
financés par le même organisme le cipdr
qui nous a pas parlé d'ailleurs
deux ans de d'octobre à janvier de
novembre 2000 20 jusqu'à janvier
3 mois même
ah non novembre vous voyez 2020 oui
j'étais à 2022 excusez
30 mois quasiment d'accord
novembre de novembre à novembre deux
fois c'est 24 mois décembre janvier de
24 26 mois ce qu'on voit très
précisément ça c'est une information
nouvelle
si vous voulez elle pose pas de problème
par rapport à vous pose un problème à
moi rien ne pose problème évidemment et
puis c'est pas le sujet le sujet c'est
en constat et vous avez j'allais dire
une même structure qui vous finance en
parallèle
sur deux montants différents pour des
actions supplémentaires alors que vous
allez donc compter un contrat à temps
plein bien on le note nous on l'avait
interrogé plutôt dans l'autre sens au
départ de connaissons pas ce contrat en
disant est-ce que ça couvre pas
finalement une activité de consultant
parce qu'on sentait bien que cette
activité consultante existait vous nous
l'avez confirmé elle existe mais elle a
été traitée à part du fond Marianne
c'est ce que vous nous dites très bien
alors
on revient
[Musique]
on revient sur un donc le sujet là aussi
qui pose une difficulté
non pas par rapport à l'association en
tant que telle mais à la manœuvre en
tant que telle de l'administration qui
est en fait il y a eu des très
clairement et puis on l'a bien compris
il y a eu des négociations préalables en
réalité sur cette action spécifique il y
a peu d'acteurs qui sont en capacité de
faire vous sollicite vous déposez un
dossier et ce dossier il est déposé tout
simplement avant même que le fond
Marianne ne soit créé voilà ça c'est
l'effet mais j'allais dire que
de ce point de vue là
le sujet porte plutôt sur la façon dont
l'administration fait les choses voilà
bien d'accord mais on veut bien le on le
spécifique bien et d'autre part le
comité de programmation
[Musique]
une personne que je qualifierais de
rédacteur 1 il y en a eu deux rédacteurs
rédacteur 1 a participé également
comprendrez encore une fois que je ne se
jetterai pas en pâture les noms donc
rédacteur 1 à participer cyril caronaga
a participé et moi-même donc
je parle de rédacteur 1 de façon
anticipée la personne avec laquelle une
des personnes avec laquelle j'avais
pensé intellectuellement de projet et
qui va qui allait nous rejoindre
quelques mois plus tard comme salarié je
l'ai associé à la réflexion et
évidemment nous avons conçu ensemble à
trois dans une logique comme on dit
communément de ping-pong peut-être même
à 4 puisque il y a rédacteur ou
rédactrice 1 et donc j'imagine qu'il y a
un rédacteur 2 dans le rédacteur 2 est
venu après il n'a pas travaillé sur n'a
pas travaillé sur le projet directement
il a travaillé sur d'autres aspects mais
pas sur le projet tel qui a été présenté
en avril
d'accord
et quels sont donc les pièces puisqu'il
y a eu un débat vous êtes un peu venu
tout à l'heure sur les pièces qui ont
été envoyées à ce moment là
donc le dossier peut-être que il
comprend quoi
je peux vous retrouver l'e-mail exact
mais outre le CERFA
il y a quatre de mémoire 4 documents
trois ou quatre documents qui sont
demandés je sais pas et vous êtes sur un
montant de 650000 euros c'est celui-là
on est sur 135000 ah non non pas du tout
on est sur un montant
de
une demande de subventions à financer à
100%
pour une première année à 635600
la première année 635 du président
voilà donc on est bien d'accord alors ce
dossier arrive il arrive donc d'ailleurs
directement
chez le préfet Ravel
par mail notamment chez le préfet de
Ravel et ensuite comment comment
finalement se déroule
le débat
entre finalement cette réception de
premier dossier si je puis dire
à un moment donné on vous demande de
revoir
sa présentation son montant comment ça
comment ça se passe
euh dans dans cette première phase après
réception du dossier de 635000 25 pardon
avec une première année 635000 alors ce
que je vous disais tout à l'heure dès le
moment où le 9 avril Cyril caronagran
envoie aussi PDR cette demande de
subvention telle que validée
politiquement par le cabinet de Madame
Schiappa je laisse Cyril caronagaran
traité avec ses interlocuteurs aussi PDF
nous n'allons plus avoir de aucune
nouvelle
et moi j'apprends par voie de presse
à travers une interview de la ministre
qu'il y a un appel à projet
appelé fond Marianne qui est mis en
place donc autour du 20 21 avril
quelques jours plus tard je crois 4-5
jours plus tard Cyril car on a garant
désolé je ne sais pas s'il m'a contacté
par email ou par téléphone me dit qu'il
a reçu une communication du cpdr
l'invitant
à reformuler la candidature du 9 avril
en l'intégrant en répondant au projet
appelé son mariage
pour moi
je trouve rien à redire si tu une
question de d'habillage administratif
à ce stade il y a rien qui me choque
j'aurais dû peut-être être un peu plus
vigilant parce qu'à partir de là on va
rentrer dans un processus tout à l'heure
j'ai utilisé un mot lourd j'estime avoir
été piégé j'estime avoir été
instrumentalisée j'espère qu'ils l'ont
fait inconsciemment j'espère qu'ils
l'ont fait inconsciemment et
involontairement mais j'ai été
instrumentalisé et j'ai été trahi et je
pèse mes mots et je vais vous expliquer
pourquoi parce que lorsque nous
discutons au sein du cabinet je dis bien
trois choses première des choses je
n'accepterai jamais de m'engager dans
une opération ponctuelle d'une année ah
il faut que ça soit plus réanien annuel
2 je ne vais pas aller
en quête de subvention je ne sais pas le
faire et l'association qui a été
désignée pour porter le projet ne s'est
pas le faire non plus n'a pas l'habitude
de faire donc je sollicite en subvention
une subvention 100%
troisièmement
pour que le projet soit réalisé
puisqu'il a été
validé politiquement il fallait qu'on
prenne en compte que le travail coûte en
chair en France les salaires coûtent
cher en France et qui étant donné que
tout le projet reposé sur du potentiel
humain il fallait suivre au niveau
financier à partir de là de mais ça
c'est ça allait glissé de façon je vais
là je vous demande vraiment d'être
patient et quand je vous demandais tout
à l'heure de prendre de la hauteur là je
vous demande vraiment d'être patient et
de m'écouter attentivement je me permets
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le rapporteur monsieur le
président
première étape Cyril caronagarran reçoit
donc cet email pour lui dire de
reformuler de sa demande dans le cadre
de l'appel à projet pour Marianne
et candidate pour le compte de l'US oppm
dans le cas du fromage
quelques jours plus tard il envoie donc
un deuxième projet pour le compte du
fond Marianne et l'explicite l'ensemble
du projet où là il y a un CERFA d'un
million
50050000 euros sur trois ans
avec
une première année publiée dans la
préparation de ce CERFA il a des
échanges et surtout par mail que j'ai vu
sur ces sur ces échanges il commence par
lui dire nous allons nous allons
financer que 60% de la première année
bon il fait donc ce deuxième CERFA qu'il
envoie en mai
et à partir
pardonner mon imprécision les 22 ou 23
mai
j'apprends d'abord par mes sources
personnelles que la candidature allait
probablement très même très probablement
être retenu et j'apprends par Cyril
carbonagaran 4 jours ou 5 jours plus
tard qu'il a reçu un mail en lui disant
que le projet allait très probablement
en tout cas avait toute ses chances
d'être retenu nous sommes mis
immédiatement au travail il se trouve
que en chimie au travail parce que je
suis en confiance etc et donc
on m'apprend que finalement c'est 350
000 euros pour l'année 2021 que ça ne
correspond que qu'il pouvait pas
financer l'administration on peut pas
financer plus de 60% et qui nous
appartenait d'aller chercher des
subventions ailleurs bon
j'ai fait contre
passez-moi l'expression maladroite
je vais le contexte contre mauvaise
fortune bon coeur c'est à dire que je
m'étais engagé j'ai commencé à m'engager
auprès des gens j'ai commencé à mettre
élaborer le projet etc et la
progressivement le projet se dénaturer
par son soutien financier et se vider de
sa substance de fait et on arrive au
final à des allers-retours incessants
après même la notification entre Cyril
car on a garant et l'administration qui
va lui demander de les dernières
modifications avant la signature de la
convention fin juillet 2021 c'est-à-dire
près de deux mois et demi voire près de
trois mois après trois mois après la
notification alors après la
multiplication alors que les contrats
travaillent après parce que
on va rester là d'abord
pouvez-vous nous dire
comment donc alors c'est dans ces
discussions donc vous dites comme vous
vous n'y participez pas
que finalement on passe de 635 000 a
d'abord un montant de 300 000 au milieu
nous sommes d'accord quel montant de
300000 il y a eu un moment donné une
fichage de 300000 après le comité le
premier comité
attribution du 13 avril donc vous n'êtes
pas informé de cela je suis pas formé et
vous n'avez pas participé ensuite à une
discussion quelconque entre ce moment-là
c'est-à-dire le mois d'avril et le
comité de sélection qui affiche un
montant de
355 355
000 donc il y a une remontée
parfaitement je dirais sur la même
posture ou explication que la ministre
c'est-à-dire que vous êtes
concerné par le projet mais vous
finalement vous tenez à distance pour
qu'il y ait je dirais pas de
rapports
je ne précise rien du tout vous allez
retirer tout de suite ce que vous venez
de dire aucune posture chez moi vous
entendez il y a aucune posture je ne
suis pas un homme politique déclaration
vous retirez tout de suite je n'ai rien
de comparable avec Madame Chapat c'est
clair rien de compliqué rien de la même
manière que j'ai fait observer hier à
madame la ministre
sur la question de l'équité et de la
transparence elle est utilisée les mêmes
mots que l'inspection générale de
l'administrations
je suis dans aucune posture monsieur je
vous réponds sincérité et avec honnêteté
transparence et bien arrêter de me
lancer à la figure des choses rien à la
figure j'ai le droit de formuler de
reformuler comme j'ai fait tout à
l'heure pour être sûr d'avoir bien
compris donc vous venez de nous donner
des éléments vous avez été convié on va
poursuivre à une réunion avec notamment
le directeur de cabinet de Madame
Schiappa et le secrétaire général du
cpdr le 22 avril 2021
pouvez-vous nous décrire le déroulement
de cette réunion et est-ce qu'à ce
moment-là le niveau de la subvention a
été évoquée
non monsieur le rapporteur
finalement donc il y a une seconde
demande de combien de leur rappeler on a
déjà parlé de 355000 euros qui est
adressé pouvez-vous nous indiquer les
raisons qui ont conduit le SEPM a déposé
un deuxième montant avec un montant donc
rehaussée de subventions même si j'ai
entendu vous nous avez vous nous avez
dit il y a quelques instants que le 300
000 vous ne vous en aviez entendu parler
pour le coup si j'interprète
par les médias mais vous n'avez jamais
puisque la demande initiale était de 635
000 vous vous n'avez jamais eu
connaissance d'une proposition à 300 000
d'abord votre lecture est fausse parce
que je ne dirige pas un cabinet
fausse parce que Cyril karunagaran
administrativement il n'est pas sur mes
ordres c'est plutôt le contraire vous
avez une lecture fausse parce que vous
m'attribuez une sorte de non non non je
ne peux pas vous laisser dire ce que
vous avez dit
le directeur vous n'êtes pas là pour
Monsieur on est là pour avoir des
échanges à poser et sur le rapporteur
vous faites
vous faites un raccourci non je pose des
questions un raccourci je ne sais pas
pourquoi je ne suis pas de vous ne
faites un raccourci malheureux je vous
le dis vous faites un raccourci
malheureux vous ne comparez à Madame
Schiappa je n'ai absolument rien
absolument pas ce que j'ai mis sur le
fond ni sur la force c'est clair c'est
mais d'abord vous n'avez pas de ni
d'ordre ni je vous demande d'aller
excusez-moi je pense que vous devez
garder et vos nerfs et votre maîtrise
nous essayons de le faire et poursuivons
et je vous le dis je suis quelqu'un vous
savez je suis quelqu'un d'assez entier
je respecte les institutions et je
respecte les gens qui me respectent mais
j'ai le moment où on me respecte plus je
vais aller sur un autre temps je vous le
dis tout de suite
mais je préfère mais je n'ai jamais
changé de trajectoire et vous pourrez
regarder au long des auditions j'essaie
d'ailleurs d'être assez constant
certains disent même que c'est bien ils
apprécient cette forme de sérénité voilà
je vous dis
alors regardons la sérénité c'est pour
c'est pour l'honneur de l'institution
que vous représentez et pour tout le
monde c'est pour l'honneur de la
situation et au dessus de vous donc
c'est pour l'honneur de la situation
s'il vous plaît
s'il vous plaît vous aussi s'il vous
plaît il n'y a pas d'accusation à porter
vous le redis voilà revenons peut-être
parmé revenons sur cette réunion du 22
avril il y a eu une réunion le 22 avril
et la question est-ce que vous y étiez
bien cette réunion le 22 avril ce n'est
pas une réunion le 22 Avril c'est une
invitation que je reçois pour
être reçu par Madame Marlène Schiappa
ce que je vous ai dit ce que vous avez
dit c'est à dire qu'après elle a pas pu
initialement elle a été retenue par un
engagement auprès du président de la
République ou du Premier ministre je
m'appelle plus honnêtement en tout cas
par un événement important
et par conséquent le cabinet m'a fait
savoir que je serai reçu par le
directeur de cabinet et pendant une
heure nous avons discuté avec le
directeur du cabinet du projet encore
une fois ce que vous a dit le directeur
de cabinet est vrai à aucun moment il
n'y a eu d'engagement financier ni de sa
part ni de la part de la ministre ni de
la part du cabinet
nous avons encore une fois affiner le
projet et il voulait se tenir au courant
pour le compte de la ministre des
détails des détails qui que que recevait
ce projet donc qui a pris ensuite la
décision donc de modifier le
montant du dépôt du dossier donc d'avoir
un deuxième dossier déposer à hauteur de
355000 euros monsieur karunagaran
quand je vous dis
c'est pas pour me dérober encore une
fois je vous raconte des faits d'accord
donnez moi juste une réponse je vous non
non mais c'est ce que je suis en train
de faire en étant le plus détaillé même
si ça vous embête parce que je pense que
le l'heure du déjeuner est proche etc et
vous avez beaucoup
on va prendre si vous voulez bien le
temps qu'il faut pour que vous puissiez
comprendre OK et on va parler calmement
ne me venez pas me piquer au vif et je
demandais de garder mes nerfs je ne
viens donc je n'ai encore une fois
encore une fois
dès le moment où on rentre dans une
traduction
administrative et financière d'un projet
que j'ai porté intellectuellement je
remets l'ensemble des éléments que nous
avions préparés ensemble avec Cyril
caronagarran à Cyril caronagran qui va
se charger de la traduction
administrative administrative de ce
projet en sa qualité en sa qualité cela
ne vous a pas échappé de président de
l'association d'accord et donc c'est lui
qui va mener l'ensemble des discussions
avec l'administration pour mettre en
application ce projet d'un point de vue
administratif et financier voilà et à
partir de là ce n'est pas pour me
dérober mais ça parce que ce n'est pas
mon rôle ce n'est pas mon rôle ce n'est
pas mon rôle et encore moins dans la
répartition des rôles qui étaient les
nôtres de rester en contact avec
l'administration j'ai bien compris vous
avez dit à plusieurs reprises la
traduction administrative j'allais vous
poser la question et financière mais
vous avez ajouté ce qui me paraît
cohérent moi j'ai juste besoin de
comprendre je vous dis la chronologie
des faits elle est différente séquences
c'est heureux que vous aurez s'il vous
plaît
n'ayons pas de remarque des obligeantes
ça ne sert à rien ça n'est jamais bon
pour je dirais la sérénités
des éléments complémentaires d'ailleurs
ont été déposés sur le dossier sur le
projet est-ce que ces éléments
vous ont été demandés et le cas échéant
à quel moment puisque pour passer avoir
un comment dirais-je un montant de
dossier supplémentaire dans le cadre du
fond Marianne ça a été des échanges avec
le cabinet en lien non absolument pas
encore une fois je vous redis
factuellement ce que je vous ai dit et
qui est facilement
je dirais
qui peut être facilement vérifié puisque
tout ceci est documenté ce qui est
documenté ce sont des échanges
ininterrompus entre
pardon le cabinet de Monsieur Gravel ou
les services de Monsieur Gravel et Cyril
karunaga d'accord
ce sont ce sont ces deux personnes qui
enfin ces deux personnes c'est plusieurs
je sais pas si Cyril était en contact
avec une ou deux plusieurs personnes
monsieur le rapporteur il était en
contact avec l'administration et c'est
l'administration qui lui demandait
d'ajuster de doux plusieurs versions que
vous avez probablement dans le dossier
plusieurs versions de CERFA de et même
des emails qui disent clairement
nous vous prions de 3 alors Cyril car on
a garant qui envoie nous vous prions de
trouver ci-joint une version actualisée
de notre dossier de candidature
actualiser c'est à dire qu'on lui a
demandé d'actualiser et ça c'est le 10
mai 2021 par la suite il reçoit un autre
email
comment dire visiblement de la personne
chargée de l'examen du dossier et qui
lui dit je me permets de vous écrire au
sujet d'un problème dans votre demande
subvention nous sommes le 25 juin un
mois après un mois après la notification
monsieur le rapporteur le budget du
projet indique toutes leurs ressources
et non uniquement celle des actions etc
donc un mois après un mois après la
notification l'administration s'aperçoit
qu'il y aurait des erreurs ne vous
inquiétez pas j'étais même pas au mois
de juin mais c'est très bien vous vous
donnez des éléments il y a aucun
problème que les échanges je ne sais pas
comme d'autres ont dit moi je sais qui
était en contact et ces documenter très
bien venons-en à l'objet de la le temps
de la réalisation du projet donc j'ai
bien compris le rôle que vous aviez
porté qui était dans ce projet qui était
dans naître je dirais la tête pensante
et la avec la vision stratégique et
l'architecture de ce projet qui je le
devine vous a pris vous l'expliquer
beaucoup de temps
sachant sauf faire de ma part que votre
contrat de travail prévoyez un contrat
de travail à mi-temps c'est bien ça à
plein temps
bon voilà donc d'accord
oui mais je comme j'avais un doute par
rapport à des éléments avec
35 ans
de travail très supérieure à la normale
et j'apprécie un certain nombre de
personnes de par le monde qui vous
appréciez ou pas
c'est apprécié votre déclaration je ne
porte pas de qualification sur vos
capacités quelles qu'elles soient je ne
me permettrai pas
quel finalement quel regard portez-vous
aujourd'hui sur les réalisations qui ont
été financées avec les crédits du fond
Marianne par votre association l'uspm
est-ce que vous considérez quels sont je
dirais en tout point conforme à ce que
vous imaginiez à l'échelle de
l'enveloppe qui vous a été attribué
est-ce que vous avez rencontré des
difficultés ou des obstacles
particuliers qui vous amener à réduire
l'ambition revoir les moyens est-ce que
vous pouvez nous en dire plus par
rapport à tout le travail que vous avez
fourni en contrepartie de la subvention
accordée je vous remercie monsieur le
rapporteur à partir du moment où
nous avons signé la Convention et reçu
les fonds fin juillet je précise que les
fonds et vous le savez qui ont été
versés mais c'est toujours mieux de le
rappeler c'est l'oeuvre à hauteur de 250
266 250 euros et non pas 357000 euros
266 250 euros
très vite nous sommes mis au travail
évidemment j'étais conscient que étant
donné que tout a été budgété sur 635000
euros il fallait tout diviser par 3 et
divisé par 3 notamment le nombre de
postes à créer c'est à dire que
j'ambitionnais de pouvoir compter sur
au moins 6 personnes la première année
et il fallait de fait divisé par 3
c'est-à-dire qu'arrivée à peu près trois
personnes enfin pas à deux parce que
c'était il y avait un taux
incompressible sinon il y avait rien qui
se réalisait surtout que
je dirais nous devions initialement
selon le projet investir l'ensemble des
réseaux sociaux et donc par conséquent
il était question de lancer
des comptes internet assez vite et
d'être dans une production
je dirais de qualité afin de légitimer
l'identité que nous comptions créer en
l'occurrence ce collectif comme nous
l'avons appelé ce collectif hilaïque la
première difficulté que j'ai rencontré
c'est j'ai compris très vite et
davantage entre octobre en novembre que
je m'étais engagé dans un projet qui
était morning
pour la simple raison qu'il n'était plus
pérennisable puisque
j'ai compris à travers une discussion
avec Christian Gravel qu'il n'irait pas
vers un financement de l'année 2
pour des raisons que j'ignore mais en
tout état de cause il m'a dit clairement
qui avant même le bilan en nous venions
à peine de commencer c'est à dire que
nous avions commencé
il y a eu un échange assez vif malgré la
sympathie qu'on a mais très franc et oui
je suis comme ça monsieur le rapporteur
parce que vous savez la franchise c'est
du respect aussi quand on regarde les
gens dans les yeux on leur dit ce qu'on
pense c'est les respecter je ferme la
parenthèse
donc on a eu un échange assez vif
sur le fait
qu'avec les moyens dont on me donnait
qui était très éloigné de ce qui était
validé initialement par le cabinet je ne
pouvais pas en l'état mettre en
application le projet et que valider par
le cabinet validé politiquement par le
cabinet le projet validé politiquement
par le projet mais pas le budget le
projet je dis bien le projet monsieur le
Président je parle du projet le projet
validé par le cabinet que de fait quand
je vous dis j'ai le projet d'acheter 10
voitures et je souhaiterais que vous les
financier vous pouvez me dire oui
j'accepte que vous achetiez des voitures
vous voyez
donc
la validation politique était très
éloignée de la traduction administrative
et financière du projet d'accord et on
est on est parti de quelque chose du
volonté politique qui a les mobiliser
des moyens
ah finalement une absence de volonté
politique la réduction de l'ambition la
communication la communication a été
faite avec tambour et trompette pardon
et plus rien c'est à dire dès le moment
où la ministre a capitalisé
politiquement à travers sa queue
communication totalement hallucinante
parce que d'abord il était question de
ne pas communiquer et ne pas faire de
publicité sur le sujet déjà pour la
sécurité des personnes déjà pour la
sécurité des personnes la tenue parole
ensuite non mais elle n'a jamais
communiqué
vous savez certains sujets il y a des
institutions dans ce pays qui
travaillent dans la discrétion qui n'ont
pas besoin qui n'ont pas besoin de
claironner sur tous les toits du
rappeler ce qu'ils font et qui et qui
sont très efficaces dans ce qu'il fait
les gens qui commencent à claironner sur
ce qu'ils font sont ceux qui font le
moins générale et sur l'objet on a bien
compris vous et d'autres nous ont
tenue des discours et des expressions
convergentes donc il y a pas de problème
donc à partir de là si vous voulez je
comprends en octobre que ce sera
difficilement réalisable
je fais malgré tout tous les efforts
pour essayer de monter quelque chose de
crédit je j'attire votre attention sur
une chose qui est essentielle et parce
que elle a été chez l'une des critiques
qui est formulée par les médias et
probablement aussi par vous même
par le rapport de l'IGA le pathétique
rapport de l'hygiène je peux vous dire
pourquoi je le traite de pathétique
c'est que est-ce qu'il y a un contrat ou
une convention qui donne
un chiffre
est-ce que si on aurait fait au lieu de
500 productions 1000 ça aurait été
suffisant ça aurait été insuffisant
en gros on vous dit on va vous financer
une armée pour aller combattre l'armée
de Poutine et finalement vous finance
une petite milice et on vous dit
pourquoi vous n'avez pas battu l'armée
de Poutine enfin c'est quand même
surréaliste vous avez des islamistes qui
ont 10 ans d'avance sur vous d'accord
vous donnez trois Francisco à une
association et vous vous demandez
pourquoi les résultats ne sont pas suivi
mais merci à ce stade si vous voulez
bien je vais poursuivre les deux
dernières questions à ce stade votre le
Prix de la saison monsieur Karine
lagaran dans l'audition auquel il a
répondu
nous a déclaré que finalement aucune
demande complémentaire de subvention à
l'endroit notamment des deux régions ce
qui faisait partie du projet initial
n'avait été adressé pour
participer au cofinancement de votre
projet
ça peut s'entendre mais est-ce que vous
avez une explication sur le fait de
n'avoir pas même sollicité et adresser
ces deux demandes de subvention pourquoi
là pourquoi y avoir renoncé très en
amont
j'espère que j'accepterai que vous
entendrez ce que j'ai à vous dire
sincèrement
d'abord j'ai adressé une demande de
façon informelle et même plusieurs
demandes à des régions je les citerai
pas parce que c'est resté au stade de la
formelle et je vais vous dire les
réponses attendez juste le parce que
le quel matériel ça se matérialise
comment l'informel
par des rencontres des réunions que j'ai
sollicité parce que j'étais obligé
d'aller essayer de chercher un
complément j'ai sollicité des et on m'a
répondu clairement d'ailleurs l'un de
mes interlocuteurs a fait cette
bouteille volontairement en me disant
non je ferai en sorte à ce que cette
région ne finance pas le fond Marlène
il a pas dit le fond Marianne le fond
Marlène pourquoi parce que elle a fait
une communication tellement personnelle
à la veille je vous rappelle quand même
le contexte mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs vous êtes des élus et vous
connaissez le cynisme politique mieux
que moi et vous l'exercer certainement
mieux que moi aussi la politique
il faut pas vous dire ce que vous avez
dit donc je vous dis juste ce qui m'a
été dit et qui intègre une logique de
cynisme politique nous sommes à la
veille d'une élection présidentielle des
régions
qui avaient des divergences politiques
avec Marlène Schiappa et le camp de
Marlène Schiappa
n'était pas je dirais très pompe à
soutenir un projet qui est devenu le
projet Marlène Schiappa et des gens de
votre camp
les gens de votre camp politique
c'est que des gens qui sont candidats à
la candidature n'ont pas forcément envie
à la veille d'une élections
parce que nous avons encore un centre de
question
vous savez les Français ils regardent
ceux qui s'y intéressent ils porteront
le jugement qu'il souhaiteront ce qui
compte c'est que la démocratie puisse
exercer sereinement dans le respect à la
fois des débats et des personnes et
surtout du sujet
dire amen ne vous apporte rien et
n'apporte rien de constructif au débat
perdez-moi de vous le dire une dernière
question quel regard portez-vous sur
la demande de à la suite de l'inspection
générale de l'administration
qui vous est adressé de rembourser une
partie des sommes versées parce qu'elle
ne correspondrait pas à la convention
qui était
objet de la subvention
fléchée à l'endroit de votre et au
bénéfice de votre association
d'abord je demanderai au rédacteur en
tout cas je conseillerais ne serait-ce
pas respect pour l'administration au
rédacteur de ce rapport de corriger
quelques petites erreurs qui ne sont pas
si petites que ça puisqu'on peut pas
faire un rapport sur un tel sujet on se
trompant sur la date d'annonassassinat
terroriste donc
l'enseignant de Conflans-Sainte-Honorine
n'a pas été tué dans la date qui figure
dans le rapport ce qui peut paraître un
détail comme le dirait certains sur des
sujets importants mais qui n'est pas à
mes yeux un détail parce que ça montre
et ça prouve la légèreté et la
précipitation le manque de rigueur avec
lequel ce rapport a été écrit l'IGA est
dans une attitude d'autodégétation de
l'administration en essayant de trouver
des lentilles on n'est pas ici
je vous parle d'un rapport oui mais ce
rapport vous avez un processus d'auto
légitimation va dès l'empistes en
l'occurrence Cyril karlagaran et
moi-même et accessoirement monsieur
Gravel vous avez vous avez le droit
d'avoir tous les avis que vous souhaitez
sur le rap je peux vous parler des
erreurs
factuelles ça vous intéresse pas
monsieur le Président
du rapport donc qui mentionne des
erreurs
attendez la question n'est pas celle-là
que vous ayez des commentaires à faire
sur un rapport où vous êtes cité ben
c'est la moindre des choses 60 ans que
vous ayez une réponse à faire à lija
vous la ferez et vous leur donnerez vous
leur enverrez je le ferai pas enfin vous
en avez la liberté ce que je veux dire
faire voilà il y a aucun problème
là-dessus non nous on vous dit au-delà
de de ce truc restons sur le truc on
léger à vous demande
rien mais demande à l'administration de
demander un remboursement à peu près de
la moitié des montants que vous a été
alloué
voilà avez-vous un commentaire à faire
sur ce point d'abord je conteste le fond
et la forme de certains des accusations
qui sont mentionnées je prendrai l'une
d'elles et pardon qui montre en quoi
encore la légèreté et la médiocrité du
texte en prétend que l'US oppm aurait
loué un bureau sans l'utiliser
manque de chance c'est la chose qu'il
fallait pas écrire vous savez pourquoi
parce que dans ma triste vie je suis
accompagné tous les jours par deux
fonctionnaires de police au moins
j'appelle donc votre commission
d'enquête de façon totalement officielle
à se rapprocher du service de la
protection du ministère de l'Intérieur
et leur demander de vous fournir un
document qui pourrait attester que
chaque matin au sortir de mon domicile
mais officiers de sécurité
m'accompagnaient au bureau qui a été
loué pour le compte de la réalisation du
projet hilaïque donc là vous êtes sur
une réponse sur environ de mémoire je
suis soumis de dépenses voilà je suis
sincèrement et oui mais un deux choses
qui est totalement gravissime on va
jusqu'à vous expliquer et expliquer elle
est l'opinion publique puisque c'est
public
que Cyril caronagaran est peut-être
accessoirement moi-même Orion fait de
l'abus de faiblesse sur deux personnes
membres de l'association qui aurait
signé des documents qui peut-être
n'auraient-ils pas signé s'ils étaient
en plein possession de leurs moyens tout
ça parce que j'ai dit on audition on est
totalement transparent comme je le suis
avec vous que nos deux amis
pour le premier eu un covidon
avec effectivement des difficultés de
santé et pour le second eu un problème
de santé qu'il a sauf que ils ont oublié
les choses ces deux personnes sont deux
gendarmes à la retraite l'un à des
activités associatives très régulières
il est médecin du GIGN et de second et
employé aujourd'hui dans une grande
entreprise où il gère la sécurité
comment on peut vous raconter que en
gros il y avait deux vieillards à côté
de nous qui étaient grands battèrent et
dont on a
de la diffamation c'est ce jeu condamne
de la demande de remboursement je crois
pas que non pas du tout nous sommes dans
le sujet vous savez pourquoi nous sommes
dans le sujet parce que quand un rapport
est truffé de mensonges et de
contre-vérité j'irai moi même si c'est
pas moi qui serait sollicité c'est
l'association j'irai moi porter ce
combat devant les tribunaux je vais
porter le combat devant les tribunaux et
je vais te montrer je vais aider Cyril
carbonara à démontrer que le
inapte et inapte ça relève de votre
appréciation toute personne et le
remboursement ça sera une décision de
justice qui remboursement doit avoir
très bien
alors d'autres points
en mars 2022 il y a un avenant qui vous
est envoyé pour prolonger du 28 février
2022 31 mai 2022 la période autour de
laquelle pour être réalisée le projet
illaique ce qu'il a pris du retard au
démarrage on va dire bon
vous êtes le permis de terminer certains
projets le cas échéant lesquels et j'ai
hâte toujours mais n'allez pas ne voyait
pas ça comme une provocation si je vous
redis l'igéa n'a pas trouvé trace de cet
avenant en tout cas lui a pas fourni
est-ce qu'il va être bien été pris alors
c'est une difficulté qui a eu
effectivement et dont j'ai eu
connaissance
je saurais très vous dire avec précision
je crois à la rentrée
2000 2022 c'est-à-dire vers août
septembre 2022
d'abord de la part de Cyril caronagaran
ensuite de la part de Christian Gravel
qui m'a fait savoir je parle de ce
dernier Christian Gravel qui m'a fait
savoir qu'il avait envoyé
qu'ils n'ont qu'il devait
un avenant devait être signé entre
l'association et ses services et que
manifestement Cyril car onagaron ne lui
a pas envoyé j'ai demandé à Cyril car on
a garant ce qu'il en était il m'a dit
qu'il l'avait envoyé mais que
visiblement l'administration n'avait pas
trouvé trace ils sont restés dans ce
dialogue jusqu'à je ne sais pas fin 2022
où une seconde ou une troisième fois
j'en sais rien Cyril car onagarra a
envoyé un avenant recommandé
signé de par ses soins et n'a jamais
reçu la partie contre signé voilà ce que
je sais de cette de cet aspect de la
difficulté
très bien juste une dernière précision
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Rapporteur si vous permettez parmi les
difficultés aussi que nous avons
rencontré c'est que
nos productions j'étais obligé de les de
les
disons les baissés à partir de janvier
février
pour une raison double d'abord on savait
que nous ne pouvions pas en tout cas
l'association ne pouvait pas reconduire
des CDD des deux rédacteurs parfois de
moyens et la deuxième chose
on était rentré dans une dans une
période de campagne électorale et par
conséquent il devenait très difficile
de traiter la plupart des sujets qui
étaient les nôtres puisque les sujets
qui étaient les nôtres étaient préemptés
d'une certaine façon par deux chapelles
idéologiques extrémistes d'extrême
droite je ne vais pas vous citer les
deux candidats d'extrême droite et
l'extrême gauche je ne vais pas vous
citer les candidats d'extrême gauche on
est rentré dans cette contradiction et
je dois vous dire que Christian Gravel
m'avait appelé pour me dire de faire
très attention à ne pas
faire de tweets qui pourraient polluer
la pré-campagne ou ensuite la campagne
électorale je m'y étais engagé et
d'ailleurs après c'est sans me parler de
l'association en question
il m'a dit qu'il avait des difficultés
avec une association et qu'il voulait
attirer mon attention parce qu'il savait
qu'on était d'une certaine façon plutôt
susceptible de
contredire pour utiliser un euphémisme
un certain nombre de candidats qui
portaient des valeurs qui étaient bien
éloignées de celle que nous défendons
bien monsieur cifaoui nous avons
entendu sur ce point donc pas trace de
la venant signée vous confirmez la
position de l'igias sur ce point bon
d'après les échanges de courriel et
téléphoniques qui nous ont été transmis
l'association semble avoir été et quand
on dit semble c'est pour vous permettre
pour nous permettre de vous poser une
question mais nous avons une petite
appréciation sur le semble avoir été
très peu réactif vous demande du
Secrétaire général au point même de
cesser de répondre aux sollicitations
entre novembre 2022 et février 2023 et
là comme vous dites voilà on a tous les
éléments sur ce point
est-ce que vous pouvez nous expliquer
pourquoi
alors là aussi et en fait ça accrédit de
ce que je disais tout à l'heure qu'il
n'y avait chez moi aucune posture
ce n'est pas moi qui était qui n'était
pas joignable on vous a pas dit qu'à un
moment donné moi-même cifaoui n'était
pas joignable j'ai appris effectivement
que Cyril caronagaran pendant une
période n'était pas été difficilement
joignable je les je lui ai demandé pour
quelle raison il n'arrivait pas à se
rendre disponible il m'a fait savoir
qu'il avait des problèmes personnels de
d'état de santé lié à des proches et
qu'il allait très vite faire diligence
pour répondre aux sollicitations voilà
ce que je sais
merci
alors un point qui est un point
qui d'ailleurs fait lien avec ce que
vous avez dit tout à l'heure vous avez
dit tout à l'heure
je l'ai noté la dès le mois d'octobre je
savais que le projet était
fichu quoi bon enfin il y avait une
difficulté puisqu'il y avait plus du
tout la notion de continuité dans le
temps etc bon vous avez dit ça vous avez
dit aussi d'ailleurs que dès le départ
dès que vous avez compris ça vous avez
réduit les charges de manière assez
significative bon en tout cas vous
n'êtes pas engagé sur du long terme ce
qu'on peut comprendre si vous aviez
cette cette pensée mais pour autant vous
avez réduit les charges mais pas toutes
les charges et vous voyez où je vais en
venir c'est à dire que en réalité quand
on regarde la la règle
de subventionnement qui est liée
ancienne de 60% mais 60% sur l'ensemble
du projet pas 60% sur la somme qui vous
est
dévolue évidemment
quand on regarde la réalité des charges
qu'est-ce qu'on retrouve et bien on
retrouve essentiellement
de salaire principaux quelques salaires
complémentaires et très peu de frais
annexes
donc
si je voulais le dire bon en tenant
compte de ce que vous avez dit vous avez
réduit les charges mais pas sur vos deux
principaux salaires qui étaient quand
même le point majeur quoi du système à
ce que vous pouvez nous expliquer cela
d'abord
l'ensemble de nos chaleurs représentées
effectivement me semble-t-il 80% de de
la subvention l'ensemble des salaires et
c'est un peu moins
ah bah c'est très bien vous voyez c'est
voyez que nous sommes voilà pas très
bien j'en doute pas monsieur le
Président en tout cas c'est levé je
crois de mémoire à 140
000 euros pour l'ensemble des quatre
salaires et en plus un delta de
prestataire extérieur de l'ordre de
40000 euros je crois
nous sommes substantiellement loin de
des chiffres avancés par par certains
médias et je tiens à souligner parce que
évidemment
ne n'étant pas visiblement de grands
professionnels de l'investigation ils
ont mélangé ceux qui les rémunérations
établies sur les fonds propres de
l'association et le les salaires
imputables sur le fond Marianne nous
parlons bien des salaires imputables sur
le fond Marianne sur le fond Marianne
les salaires imputables qui m'ont été
versés personnellement sont de l'ordre
de 43000 euros sur 12 mois 43000 euros
et pardonnez-moi du Mans déclaré auprès
de l'administration fiscale
Cyril car onagara son salaire et je
crois que c'était autour de 30000 euros
imputables sur le fond mariage donc à
deux c'est 77000 euros de salaire
imputable sur le fond Marianne donc le
reste c'est par conséquent la chose
effectivement
qui n'était pas possible c'était de
réduire de réduire enfin réduire nos
salaires c'est mettre fin à nos contrats
de travail c'est soit passer à une
attitude de bénévole mais à ce moment-là
il fallait parce que bon
accessoirement je tiens à le dire je
n'ai pas centré ma vie autour de la vie
de la chose matérielle et donc je ne
suis pas rentier et comme je suis père
de famille et que j'ai des enfants à
élever il me faut gagner ma vie et
gagner ma vie à une hauteur qui me
permette justement de faire face au
quotidien pas pour un enrichissement
personnel pas pour un enrichissement
personne ça n'a jamais été ma quête
d'existence et donc oui il fallait qu'on
ait un salaire
je n'ai pas rougir face à ce salaire et
je le dis devant vous ce salaire est
conforme un contrat de travail et lié un
travail qui a été fourni c'est un
travail qui a été fourni et qui a été
apprécié uniquement sur sa partie
publiable et visible comme si lorsqu'on
se réveille le matin qu'on fait une
revue de presse pour le compte du projet
ce n'est pas du travail comme si
lorsqu'on reçoit un appel téléphonique à
22h pour pour corriger monsieur shifaoui
on est d'accord avec vous qui a une
partie de travail toujours heureusement
d'ailleurs masqué intellectuel de
préparation vous dites un professeur et
corriger copy évidemment que nous savons
tous à non
à bord de l'igéa moi j'ai pas de
compétences le fameux rapport de
l'hygiène
mais quand même quand on regarde même
nous quand on regarde la quand même le
nombre de
Visio le nombre de tweets de trucs ça
nous paraît faible on peut on peut on
peut le dire de manière courtoise ça
paraît faible d'autre part si vous
voulez
vous nous dites un peu ce projet à un
moment donné bon vous avez compris qu'il
n'allait pas aller beaucoup plus loin
et donc ça se traduit un petit peu
et vous nous dites aussi quelque chose
qui est tout à fait
confirmé que vous avez été mis en garde
sur tel ou tel sujet ou tel ou telle
façon de traiter les sujets dans le
cadre de la campagne des campagnes
électorales qui allait arriver tout ça
tout ça est vrai mais au final au final
ça fait une production extrêmement
faible par voilà extrêmement faible par
rapport à je veux dire que des gens plus
qualifiés que moi le diront nous ici on
fait un constat comme ça un peu général
mais on trouve que ça fait quand même un
truc relativement faible et d'autre part
donc
vous suites vous souhaitez continuer
votre question je sais pas peut-être
dans le prolongement juste je suis dans
le prolongement pour bien faire le lien
mais simplement
il semblerait aussi on a eu des
confirmations sur ce point que l'équipe
que vous avez recruté en fait c'était
quoi c'était de poster 2000 en réalité
entre les mi-temps voilà c'était de
l'ordre de de posséder demi bon au
départ il y a eu des relations
tout à fait
classique avec la mission qui était la
vôtre c'est-à-dire l'orientation c'était
vous qui la fixiez le contrôle
a posteriori de ce qui était produit et
réflexion sur comment modifier puis à
partir d'un certain moment mais assez
tôt et qui correspond assez bien ce que
vous dites c'est-à-dire le mois
d'octobre c'est le moment où il y a un
peu de flou sur l'opération et sur la
continuité de l'opération là par contre
plus de son plus d'image et donc
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé à ce moment-là
d'abord vous me donnez l'occasion de et
je tiens puisqu'il y a ce torrent debout
aussi et que c'est extérieur pas vous
qui alimente cette polémique à rendre
hommage aux deux rédacteurs qui ont
travaillé avec nous qui ont fait preuve
de sérieux
d'une grande qualité professionnelle et
j'espère qu'ils ne seront jamais mêlés à
cette affaire ni de près ni de loin
parce qu'ils n'ont absolument rien à se
reprocher j'assume seul sur le plan
éditorial la responsabilité
et les critiques et
les mécontentements des uns et des
autres et les considérations subjectives
et les accusations mensongères et je
veux revenir au sujet ça c'est non mais
c'est important non mais je comprends
les gens
ne répond pas à la maison
jouent leur tranquillité les gens jouent
leur avenir c'est pas quelque chose de
simple que de jouer que jeter des gens
au chien pour reprendre une expression
connaît est-ce qu'on s'est permis de
livrer quelques noms que ce soit vous
pas vous merci je tiens à le dire parce
que il y a certains journalistes
irresponsables qui sont dans une sorte
de vendetta idéologique qui sont
capables de tout et n'importe quoi voilà
je ferme la parenthèse
concernant ces deux
collaborateurs amis
participants activement à la naissance
de
je n'ai pas eu de désaccord majeur avec
eux ils m'est arrivé je vais utiliser un
gros mot que je n'aime pas du tout parce
que c'est une situation très
inconfortable que de devoir entre
guillemets censurer et production pas
pour pas pour pour
le plaisir de censurer pas pour attenter
à la liberté d'expression absolument pas
mais pour être conforme à un cahier
d'échange et faire preuve de
responsabilité la difficulté que à
laquelle j'étais confronté monsieur le
Président Monsieur le rapporteur
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
c'est que nous sommes sur des
thématiques
qui sont investis par un certain nombre
d'acteurs politiques alors je me suis
permis de laisser répondre à et de
répondre moi-même à certains acteurs
avant décembre avant décembre c'est à
dire avant l'entrée en pré campagne
je peux vous jeter le nom si vous le
souhaitez des responsables politiques et
j'assume totalement ces mois donc si
jamais demain il voit leur nom Éric
Zemmour Sandrine Rousseau c'est moi
voilà c'est pas c'est pas l'association
c'est moi qui ai répondu c'est moi qui
ai pris choix de répondre avec le compte
de l'association à des inepsies là pour
des propos racistes xénophobe l'autre
pour le soutien aux voies islamistes le
problème c'est qu'à partir de septembre
on ne pouvait plus à partir de pardon
décembre janvier ne pouvait plus et ça
devenait de plus en plus compliqué de
répondre de répondre sur le ton juste
de ne pas s'exposer à des poursuites
éventuelles
j'ai voulu incarner le projet j'ai voulu
l'incarner pourquoi l'incarner pour
pouvoir
identifier le collectif les gens y
compris qu'ils nous considéraient
de leur bord idéologique était en été
pour eux un collectif anonyme même des
amis n'étaient pas au courant que
j'étais à la tête de ce projet parce
qu'on nous m'a demandé en m'a demandé de
rester très discret sur et on m'a
empêché de de l'incarner au même titre
que je devais faire en sorte à ce qu'il
y a une porte-parole sur sur ce projet
une personne je dirais figure médiatique
qui aille et j'avais en tête la personne
qui devait jouer ce rôle on m'a refusé
ça donc si vous voulez un moment donné
il faut bien comprendre ce qu'on est en
train de raconter dans cette histoire on
vous demande de vous lancer dans un
projet on vous le valide et ensuite on
vous dépouille au fur et à mesure de
l'avancement donc évidemment la
production ne peut pas suivre moi je me
lancerai jamais dans un projet qui
consiste à faire deux trois dixites par
jour ça n'a pas de sens et Twitter de
façon frénétique tous les spécialistes
vous le diront ça n'a pas de sens c'est
quand on est dans un compte
institutionnel j'ai twitté pendant une
époque sur un compte Mon Compte
Personnel énormément mais sur mon compte
personnel sur un compte institutionnel
ensuite différemment forcément donc
la même chose on parle d'une on parle
d'une feuille blanche
tout est à créer
un compte sur chaque réseau social et
donc si vous voulez à chaque fois avec
une matière assez
originale pour pouvoir attirer
l'attention
donc aujourd'hui si vous voulez bien sûr
que je ne suis pas content de virus si
vous voulez que je vous dise que je suis
satisfait de moi je suis pas je suis pas
content de moi je regrette profondément
et je ne ferai plus jamais confiance aux
institutions je le dire qui m'engage qui
m'engagerait à aller dans un travail je
ferai confiance dans voilà des relations
comme ça mais jamais jamais plus je ne
suivrai
des demandes
d'un responsable politique jamais plus
plus personne sauf dans un cadre comme
celui-ci où je suis contraint ne
modifionnera plus jamais je n'échangerai
sur mes thématiques avec aucun
responsable politique parce que j'ai
perdu confiance totalement
totalement dans l'action publique où je
vois d'ailleurs les lâchetés se
manifester par la suite il aurait fallu
que chacun assume ses responsabilités sa
petite part de responsabilité chacun a
sa petite part de responsabilité je l'ai
dit en début d'intervention il y a pas
de malversation financière dans cette
affaire il n'y en a pas il n'y avait pas
une volonté de malversation financière
mais il y a des erreurs successives
encore une fois ce n'est pas ici je le
dis donc voilà juste pour m'intérêt mais
il n'y en a pas eu de la part de
personnes bien sûr de moi-même mais je
m'engage j'ai compris pour les autres
voilà il n'y en a pas vu non mais ce que
je veux dire c'est ce qui décideront
d'éventuels mais elle va se financière
ce n'est pas nous très bien et vous le
savez et vous le savez donc nous névons
pas ce type de sujet nous essayons de
comprendre vous venez de donner les
éléments d'appréciation votre Vérité si
je peux dire non pas sur des questions
de malversation financière mais c'est
des questions de le fonctionnement du
projet pourquoi il a démarré en retard
nous le savons il a démarré en retard
pour beaucoup d'associations pas que la
vôtre pourquoi
pourquoi il s'est arrêté tout voilà en
tout cas il était empêché tôt ou mis en
difficulté tôt voilà et au final quel
est le résultat vous dites le résultat
bon vous n'avez pas satisfait voilà on
reste je reste sur vos mots voilà et et
je crois que c'est ce que nous venions
chercher vos explications dans cette
dans cette dans cette affaire la
compréhension des sujets vu par tous les
acteurs ce que nous avons vu et
effectivement en tout état de cause la
reconnaissance de responsabilité est
toujours un peu difficile à venir
naturellement voilà ce que ce qu'on peut
vous laisser l'ensemble et c'est
l'ensemble des auditions qui l'ont
montré voilà ça mais j'espère que vous
les aiderez aussi moi en tout cas je
suis là je suis pas responsable
politique je suis pas dans
l'administration à mon modeste niveau
j'assume l'ensemble de mes
responsabilités et la première erreur
que j'ai faite c'est d'avoir fait
confiance à Madame Schiappa aux équipes
de Madame Schiappa et d'avoir
foncé un peu parce que j'ai vous savez
j'ai des défauts comme tout le monde
et j'ai
qualité peut-être
c'est la sincérité la naïveté parfois
des gens engagés je suis quelqu'un
d'engagé monsieur le Président je suis
pas à quel mot aussi je suis quelqu'un
d'engagé comme vous et vous savez les
gens engagés ont parfois cette naïveté
de croire que les autres sont aussi
engagés que et quand vous êtes face au
cynisme
vous oubliez parfois que vous pouvez
être manipulé utilisé par le pouvoir
politique ça a été mon cas et par
prolongement j'ai entraîné dans mon
sillage lui se ppm Cyril caronagarran et
évidemment tous ceux qui voilà
merci Monsieur cifaoui merci de cette
audition merci Monsieur Lucifer oui je
me dois de vous dire que à titre
personnel de nos échanges je vous l'ai
dit tout à l'heure mais je vous confirme
que ça j'ai relevé tout de même un
certain nombre de contradictions entre
les déclarations des uns et des autres
lors des auditions j'ai
je l'ai parfois mentionné voilà je et en
général je fais des choses à visage
découvert comme vous l'avez vu en toute
franchise par contre et je le dis sans
aucune pensée accusatrice le président
et moi-même élément de la commission des
finances qui ont assisté à l'ensemble ou
à certaines des auditions ont pu en tous
les cas apprécier jusqu'à maintenant la
tenue des travaux ça n'empêche que les
uns les autres peuvent avoir des
expressions plus affirmée voilà avec en
mettant un ton très engagé simplement
et pour terminer je vous redis que je
regrette et je pense que vous j'espère
que c'est aussi votre cas vous n'avez
ici en face de vous et à vos côtés
pas de personnes qui ont voulu d'une
manière ou d'une autre manifester du
cynisme
on essaie simplement d'établir la
réalité des faits et ensuite d'en tirer
les enseignements pour la clarté du
débat public je vous remercie monsieur
le Président je vous remercie monsieur
le rapporteur j'entends vos propos je
vous remercie de la qualité de l'échange
je vous ai répondu franchement j'ai dit
les choses telles que je l'ai pensé et
le cynisme viser notamment ceux qui
utilisent cette commission d'enquête
veulent se faire un petit peu les danges
je dirais politiquement parlant sur des
personnes qui sont par ailleurs traînées
dans la boue avant même que la justice
ne s'exprime ce n'est pas la première
fois que le pouvoir politique ou des
élus se substituts au pouvoir judiciaire
je vous remercie merci monsieur